hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
this video is based on node.js full
course
we will begin with full course video by
understanding what exactly node.js is
next we will go through the installation
process of node.js
and make the computer ready for node.js
development
next we will have an in-depth
understanding of node.js architecture
and some of its popular modules next we
will see
how to interact with apis using the
express framework
based on node.js then we will see how to
use node.js in web applications and api
services
then we will look into the web
authentication using json web tokens
then we will look into using node.js
with database systems like mysql and
mongodb and at the end we will look into
node.js interview questions and answers
that summarize every important node.js
concept and
serve as a perfect preparation resource
for nodejs interviews
by the end of this video i can assure
you that you will have a proper
understanding of node.js concepts
and you will also be able to use this
framework in our web development
applications
so let's start with an exciting video on
node.js
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon
and never miss an update from simply
learn
welcome to this video by simply learn in
today's session
we're going to learn all about node.js
so without further ado
let's begin and look at what's in store
for us first up we'll understand what
exactly node.js is
then we'll understand the necessity of
node.js then we'll learn
about some of the parts of node.js
node.js express framework
node.js use cases and finally we'll look
at some of the industry trends
so what exactly is node.js now consider
a scenario where a user interacts with
the web application
the user only interacts with the front
end of the application
but there's a lot of work that goes
behind the scenes
now in a web application there's a front
end a server
and a database the front-end is
developed using javascript and
frameworks like angular and react
while the server is built on java php or
node.js
and the backend database that stores the
data usually consists of mysql or
mongodb
so node.js is an open source
cross-platform javascript runtime
environment
for running server-side applications it
is used to develop io intensive web
applications
like video streaming sites single page
applications
online chatting applications and other
web applications it is used by large
established companies
and newly minted startups node.js was
developed by ryan dahl in 2009 and at
the same time of this session
its latest version is v13.3.0
now that we know what node.js is let's
go ahead and look at why it was so
prevalent in the field of web
development
here are a few points first up node.js
is extremely fast
being built on google chrome's v8
javascript engine its library is
extremely fast in code execution
note package manager has around 50 000
bundles for developers
so whatever functionality is required
for an application can be easily
imported from npm
all apis of node.js library are
asynchronous
that is non-blocking it means a node.js
based server never waits for an api to
return data
node.js dramatically reduces the
processing time while uploading video
and audio files
it is also an open source platform and
is easy for beginners for web
development
the above reasons more than justified
the popularity of node.js platform
and why it is being adopted by large
number of organizations and businesses
today
so now moving on let's familiarize
ourselves with the parts of node.js
node.js consists of several components
now let's look at them one by one
first up we have modules now modules are
like javascript libraries
which are used in a node.js application
to include a set of functions
now we can use required function with
the parenthesis to include a module in a
nodejs application
node.js application has many modules to
provide basic functionality needed for a
web application
some of them could be http util fs
url query string stream and zlip
next up we have console the console
module provides a simple debugging
console that is similar to the
javascript console mechanism provided by
web browsers
now the console can print messages to
std out that prints standard output
messages
and sed to print the error messages the
next component is cluster
now node.js is built upon the concept of
single threading programming
a single instance of node.js runs in a
single thread to take advantage of
multi-core systems
the user will sometimes want to launch a
cluster of node.js processes
to handle the load a cluster can be
added to an application
in this way here's a small code for you
the next component
is global now global objects in node.js
are available in all modules
now these objects are functions modules
strings etc
some node.js global objects are
mentioned in the table you have
dir name that is the directory name file
name
exports module and require the next
component is error handling
now node.js applications experience four
types of errors
we have the standard javascript errors
system errors
user specific errors and assertion
errors now errors in node.js are handled
through exceptions
now for example let's handle an error
that would occur when we divide a number
by 0.
now this error would crash the nodejs
application and so we should handle this
error
here's a small code for you next up we
have streaming
a stream is an abstract interface for
working with streaming data in node.js
streams are objects that let you read
data or write data continuously there
are four types of streams
first one is the readable these are the
types of streams
from which data can be read writable
these are the types of streams to which
data can be written
duplex these are both readable and
writable streams
lastly we have transform these streams
can manipulate the data while it is
being read or written
moving on to the next component buffer
the javascript language
has no mechanism for reading or
manipulating streams of binary data
buffer is a module that allows handling
streams that contain only binary data
an empty buffer of length 10 can be
created by this method
next up we have domain domains provide a
way to handle
different io operations as a single
group domain module
intercepts errors that remain unhandled
there are two types of methods that are
used for intercepting these errors
firstly we have internal binding in this
case the error emitter executes its code
inside the error method
next up is the external binding now here
the error emitter is explicitly added to
a domain
via its add method the next component is
the dns
the dns module enables name resolution
for example it is used to look up the ip
addresses of host
names dns module is used to connect to a
dns server
and perform name resolution by using the
method dns.resolve the dns module is
also used for performing name resolution
without a network communication by using
the method dns.lookup
the next component is the debugger
node.js includes an out-of-process
debugging utility
accessible via a v8 inspector and
built-in debugging client
this node.js debugger is not feature
packed but supports simple inspection of
code
it can be used in the terminal by using
the inspect keyword
before the name of the javascript file
in order to inspect a file say
myscript.js
you can use the following method now
that we are familiar with all the major
parts of node.js
let's go ahead and learn about the
node.js express framework
express is a flexible node.js web
application framework
that provides a wide set of features to
develop both web and mobile applications
you can assume express as a layer built
on top of the nodejs
that helps manage the server and the
roots now let's have a quick look at
some of the core features of express
framework
it is used to design single page
multi-page and hybrid web applications
it allows setting up of middleware to
respond to http requests
it defines a routing table that is used
to perform different actions based on
the http method and url
it also allows dynamic rendering of html
pages
based on passing arguments to templates
now moving on let's take a quick example
of a simple hello world program
now this is developed using express
framework to gain a better understanding
all right first up we have the where
express now this is used to import
express framework into our node.js
application now the app.get method is a
callback function with parameters
request and response
the request object represents the http
request and has
properties for the request query string
parameters
body http headers etc the response
object
represents the http response that an
express app sends when it gets an http
request
now the application will listen to the
defined port which in this case is 8081
and variables host and port will contain
the address and the port respectively
lastly we have the console.log which is
used to show the address and port in the
command prompt
so this is what the command prompt would
look like and finally
the output is displayed on the web
browser having learned about the express
framework
now let's move on and look at the
node.js use cases
now it is no doubt that node stands out
for its
speed and intensive data exchange so top
industry leaders like nasa
paypal netflix among others incorporate
node.js
first up we have netflix the world's
leading internet television network
with over 117 million users is one of
the top
companies that trusted their services to
node.js
the reasons why the company chose to use
node.js were application scalability
and data intensive application now you
must be wondering what application
scalability is
this basically the potential of an
application to grow in time
being able to efficiently handle more
and more requests per minute
and data intensive application allows
millions of people to stream netflix
simultaneously
next up is walmart now walmart is the
world's largest company by revenue with
around 514 billion us dollars
according to the fortune global 500 list
in 2019.
again the reasons why the company chose
node.js with asynchronous i o
and efficient handling of concurrent
requests now asynchronous io which is a
form of input output processing
allows other processing to continue
before the transmission has finished
nodejs is able to efficiently handle
concurrent requests with the use of
thread pool and event queues
uber uber is an american multinational
ride-hailing company
offering services that include
peer-to-peer ride sharing
ride service healing and food delivery
the reasons why the company chose
node.js for asynchronous i o
quick iterations and active open source
community as mentioned earlier
asynchronous io permits other processing
to continue before the transmission has
finished
now quick iterations now node.js is
continually being updated and added new
features that help in further
improvement in the performance of web
servers
and finally active open source community
resolves many problems that an
organization may face
in a particular scenario next up we have
nasa
now nasa is an independent agency of the
united states federal government
responsible for the civilian space
program as well as aeronautics and
aerospace research
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were reduced access times
handling of data intensive tasks and the
fact that the servers are active 24 7.
now nasa has lots and lots of data and
using node.js has really helped them in
reducing the access times
it is also continuously handling and
working with large streams of data
node.js is highly stable which helps in
keeping the server active 24 7.
next up we have paypal now paypal is an
american company
operating a worldwide online payment
system that supports online money
transfers as opposed to traditional
methods like checks and money orders
the reasons why the company chose to use
node.js was the fact that node.js has
extremely fast build times
it allows tasks to be carried out with
fewer lines of code when compared to
other server technologies like java and
php
and nodejs being data intensive
efficiently handles a large amount of
data
next up is medium medium is a popular
online publishing platform
developed by evan williams and launched
in august 2012.
the main reasons why the company chose
to use node.js were a
data-driven applications now these
applications are ideal for being
interfaced with node.js servers
b to run a b tests now a b testing is
essentially an experiment
where two or more variants of a page are
shown to users at random and statistical
analysis
is used to determine which variation
performs better lastly
node.js server maintenance is simpler
than its counterparts
moving on to the last topic of this
session industry trends
now node.js developers are in demand
across the globe since many companies
are adopting javascript libraries
according to forbes it is one of the top
10 most in demand jobs
according to node source the total
number of node.js downloads increased by
40 percent in the last one year
the use of node.js in production has
increased dramatically
since its release in 2010. with early
adopters
such as linkedin paypal and netflix
among others
node.js has seen an exponential increase
in its use in web development
the popularity of node.js is also
accounted to javascript now since
javascript is the most
popular language as evident from a
survey conducted by stack overflow in
2019
many developers can start working on
node.js library with not much of a
learning curve
node.js developers are being offered
better salary options than other web
technology developers
according to pay scale the average
salary of a node.js developer in india
is around 6 lakhs 13 000 rupees per year
the average salary of a node.js
developer across the united states is
around 105
000 us dollars per year in this video
we'll help you install
node.js on your windows system so
without further ado
let's begin the first thing you need to
do is download node.js from their
official website
so go ahead and type download
node.js navigate to their official
website
and here you can see the 64-bit version
so go ahead and download that once the
download is done
go ahead and run the downloaded node.js
installer
accept the license agreement keep the
default settings as it is
and then say install
so with that we finished the
installation process
once node has been successfully
installed the next crucial step is
verification
now this process ensures that node has
been properly installed
to do so we first open the command
prompt and then
type in a few commands to verify the
successful installation
we type in this command node hyphen v
now this command returns the version and
if it returns the version it means it
has been successfully installed
so here we go it returns the latest
version now the final step is to update
the node package manager
now this npm is bundled with nodejs
which consists of all the repositories
and packages required for development
purposes so to do that
type in the command npm
install npm hyphen hyphen
global now that we're done with the
installation of node let's go ahead and
implement a small program
for that we make use of a text editor in
our case we've installed
vs code so go ahead and download vs code
once you're done with the installation
this is what vs code looks like so go
ahead and
click on file and create a new file it's
going to be a simple program where
you're going to print a hello world
message
on the web browser to do that we make
use of http modules
so node comes with built-in http modules
to transfer data across it
so for that we make use of a require
method we create a variable first
say var http
equals required and just say http within
single quotes now the http module can
create an http server that listens to
the server ports
and gives a response back to the client
to do that we make use of the create
server method
so let's go ahead and type the code
say http dot create
server and internally it consists of a
function
now the parameters to this function are
request
and response now the response is
basically used to write to the client
so we say response dot write and here we
type in the message
say hello world
welcome to this tutorial
once you're done with that you end the
response
so the server listens to a port number
to display the message
by default it listens to the port number
8080 so we keep that as it is
and we end it save your file say
demo.js maybe demo1.js and say save now
to run the program you have to open the
command prompt so open your command
prompt
and mention the path to your file so in
our case it's our desktop on the desktop
so cd
desktop and now to run it say node
demo1 dot js now you navigate to your
browser
and say localhost 8080 and here we go
our message is successfully displayed
so let's talk about the node.js
architecture and understand why
it's so good so to begin with
a node.js has what's called a single
threaded event loop architecture
and this allows you to be able to handle
many many
concurrent clients at the same time it's
just a
very flexible way of being able to scale
up your support for many clients
and then in addition to that we have the
javascript event based
model along with the javascript callback
mechanism
that allows you to have this standard
approach
to being able to connect with and talk
and discuss
interactions between the client and the
server
it's good to have these kind of
standards where you're not using
something that's unique
to a specific framework or a specific
technology
this just makes it so it's a more
accessible for everybody
so if we look at the actual node.js
server itself
everything centers it around the the
concept of the event loop and the event
loop has a
an event queue an operation completed
and fire requests threaded pull and then
it'll actually do the actual computation
or the file system interaction
all of this interconnects in a nice
seamless loop
the great thing again with node.js is
that it's not new technology it's been
around for almost a decade
it's very very well tried out many of
the largest websites out there are
running
node.js so let's now dig into each of
the parts of the node.js architecture
so let's talk about requests so
the way that the request works is that
you have
your framework such as angular
on the client and that will then send a
request
to the website and there's many ways
that those requests can happen through
web workers through forms
and through other interactions but at
some point a request is sent
to the server and so these requests can
be for data they can be for deleting
data they can be for updating data
they can be for interacting with
services as mentioned before
but the goal is to have some kind of
request now once that request actually
hits the server
and then we start actually getting into
the cueing and threading process
that centers around the event loop and
this is where node.js really excels
because it's able to use that single
threaded
model to be able to manage from just
even a few requests to tens of millions
of requests so it receives the actual uh
request and starts the event queue and
this is where
a single threading process starts is by
queuing
everything up appropriately and then
it then maintains the threat within a
pool
so you have the queueing process as one
action
and then you have a threaded pool which
manages those um threads as well
and then we have an event loop which you
know goes through actually
receives and processes those requests
and then finally what we're doing is
we're actually they're going to be
interacting
with a system and that could be a
database it could be a cloud system it
could be an api
file system but we're interacting with
something that's outside of the node.js
server so the node.js server itself is
doing some actions
on the server but then it's also
interact with things outside
of its own server environment and so
let's talk a little bit about that
workflow
so requests come in they go into the
event queue and they get spiraled
through the event loop
and then we have a non-blocking
operators which are going to be doing
the input output
polling uh such as kq epoll and other
services
and from there we're also going to be
then interacting with the threaded pool
and we're using the blocking operations
to manage that threaded pull
and that threaded pool is going to now
then go outside of the server
and interact with something beyond the
server so whether that is a database or
file system
or api or microservice these are things
that can be
interacted with so let's go through what
npm
is so npm itself stands for the node
package manager
no great shakes there as the name says
it's responsible for all the packages
and modules
that are bundled within node.js
so the notepad manager itself really has
two key functionalities and the first is
that
reply it is a central repository for
all packages and modules which you can
then search through
online you can go to search.nodejs.org
and you can find all of the packages and
modules that are out there
the second is that it's also a command
line or terminal
line utility that allows you to install
those packages so you can actually go
through and you can see the version
management and dependencies within those
packages
and you actually can control the
packages themselves
so why would you use npm
so npm is really useful for being able
to extend
the project you're working on so when
you're building out a project one of the
concepts i like to use is the concept of
lego bricks
um big fan of lego and what's great
about lego bricks is that they're all
individually by themselves very small
very specific functionality
but if you actually get a whole
collection of lego bricks together
you can build like crazy cool things so
think
of when you're working with the node
package manager itself
is that each of those individual pieces
that you're working with
each of those individual packages are
their own lego bricks and by themselves
you can then edit and update and
maintain that piece
um separately from the whole environment
as long as your inputs and outputs they
have
really the piece where you snap the lego
in or when you connect lego to something
else
are interacted and open and well
documented then you can actually
then use those modules effectively
throughout your project
um so you can actually then be able to
you do that you can do
version control on your codes and
dependencies you can do testing very
easily
and then once you actually get to the
point where you go yes i want to release
um
a new module you can do that effectively
using npm and it will actually go
through
and do the actual deployment for you
so let's go through the mpm installation
so the actual package manager itself is
included with the installation of
node.js so if you've installed and
you're running node.js
locally then you've already installed
the package manager
but you can also access it through
command line or terminal window
on your your data server or in your
server farm or in via the cloud
if you haven't now downloaded node.js
here's the website where you can go down
to install it and there's windows and
mac
versions of that code as well with the
installers which allow you to get up and
going
very quickly uh you want to be able to
run the installer and accept all the
default settings
just uh you know to begin with you want
to kind of have the standard setup so
that you
are most familiar with the normal
settings before you start getting to the
point where you're a master and
you're tweaking things um there is a way
that you can open up the command window
or the terminal window
and once you've actually installed
node.js to verify that
it's actually installed you can write
command node dash dash
version and i'll show them pull out the
version of node.js
that you have uh installed and then
you'll be able to see that you've got to
actually up and running
and then you can also do the same thing
for npm we can do apm
dash dash version and it actually will
then show you which version of the node
package manager you have running so you
can actually take it full advantage of
that program and verify that it's
actually up and running
so let's actually look inside of a
package
so packages themselves are actually just
json files
if you're new to this space json file is
a structured
file format that's based on javascript
it's a very xml like format for being
able to
write instructions for the actual
package itself
and so the json file forms that you know
really kind of the the heart
of each package you create um it has
all of the metadata that you'd have
about a particular object
and then it provides a root directory to
any of the applications or modules
that the package may be referencing in
addition
and it has any other additional
information about the project
that has such as dependencies and other
files that need to be included
so here we have is an example of a
package
and that would be created using npm
json script and you can actually take
this package file as it is right here
and use the command npm in it and it'll
actually
run this package and so you would
actually have it a demo application
up and running really quickly uh you can
then go ahead if you want to you can
edit any of these parameters so
like for instance if you wanted to
change the description or the version
uh or what is the the main index script
that would be written
you know these are all things that you
can edit very quickly and easily you can
just use text editor
to make any of these edits and so we
have the different metadata that can be
updated
and so this is where we go in and do a
full demo
of working with npm
so what we're going to do now is we're
actually going to go ahead and actually
run a demo of using npm
and to do that i've got three windows in
front of me right now so i have this
window here which is my terminal window
where i'll be doing all my instructions
then i
also have a folder which shows where
i'll be
putting all of the files and then
finally i'll actually have a
text editor in this case i'm using vs
code because it's free
but you can use any text editor you like
to be able to go in
and show what the code that's been
created
uh by npm in the json file so you can
actually see what it looks like
and then we'll modify it a little bit so
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and
create a new project folder so
i'm going to go in i'm just going to
move into
i'm going to do change directory i'm
going to
the project folder and we'll see down
here that we have an empty project
folder
um but for this one i'm actually going
to go ahead and i'm going to create a
new directory in this one and i'm going
to call this one
simply learn
and there we are we've created a new
simplyland folder
and we are going to move into
the simplyland folder
and so we're now in the simply land
folder uh there's nothing in that right
now
um so the first thing we want to do is
we want to take
go ahead and initialize this folder as a
project folder for working with mpm
now to do this you will have to already
installed npm
if you have no js npm comes with it
and if you want to see whether or not
you have npm installed so you can just
do npm
version and that will actually tell you
what the version of npm you have
installed is it also verifies that npm
is installed so
i've gone ahead and i've been able to
validate that i have npm installed
so what i'm now going to go ahead and do
is i'm going to initialize this folder
so to do that
just do npm init and you'll see that the
path is that we're already
in the simplyland folder and then when
you do that
it's going to ask you some questions so
what is the package name
we're going to go with the defaults for
right now and i can show you how we can
edit those in a little bit
uh we're going to go with just say yes
to all of these just by hitting
return and
you'll see here that we're going to
create a new folder called a
package.json folder
this is the instructions that we have in
the folder do you want to go ahead and
create this
we want to and it's going to go ahead
and do that and we can see now in our
folder here that we actually have
package.json so
we go ahead and open this up with
vs code here we are we can actually see
what all of the information is we can go
ahead and we can actually go
and update uh this metadata if we
want to i'm going to leave it as is for
right now
because i want to show you a couple of
other things so a lot of times when
you're actually working
with npm and the reason why you're using
npm is that you want to take advantage
of packages that are freely available in
the open source community that are
supported by
node.js and one of those is
a package called express and express is
a
lightweight framework for building out
uh
web applications similar concept to
angular or react.js i like
using it and it's also a great way to be
able to show how we can
uh install this using npm so to
install this uh you just start with the
command npm and then you type install
and then we type the name of the package
we hit enter and it goes ahead
and what you'll actually see is a couple
of things one is we have a dependency
in our package above we also have
so this is in our json package that is
now a dependency it's written in there
we can also go in and under our node
modules we actually see that we have
we scroll down we should see express
there it is express
now if we decide that we don't want to
use
express we can actually just come in and
we can write
command npm uninstall
i can type express
oops i did a typo there so let's try
that again
npm uninstall
express
and couple things going to happen one is
in our json file the dependency for
the express file has now been removed
and we can also see that under our node
modules
there are no extensions there so this is
kind of cool this allows us to be able
to see
um that we can easily add and remove
packages uh so let's just go ahead and
i'm going to install express again so
install express
npm install express
all right so it's gone ahead and it's
installed express
now one of the things that often happen
is that when you're working with a
package
the actual json package so you'll
receive
this file and you want to be able to go
ahead
and install of the
sub modules that come with it so and you
can go through you can manually install
them like this or you can actually
run an install command so you can
actually install all of them at once
i can just show you what that looks like
because we're going to actually go ahead
and simulate as if we're going to
install
bootstrap which is another
popular framework
that
and what we'll see is under the packages
that bootstrap isn't listed in there
we do have express there it is right
there
so we now come over to our
new commands we can actually write the
command npm
install
and now
site typo let's try that again
let's do npm install
okay it does help to save your file so
let's go ahead and
let's run npm install
and when you do that what we'll now
actually have
is not just express but
we'll also see that bootstrap has also
been added
now i don't recommend that you use the
star symbol which will install the
latest version of bootstrap because you
obviously haven't tested your
application against that
but it gives you an idea of of what's
happened here
now if we want to we can actually go in
here and we can say
on in install
bootstrap and it will actually remove
that
from your json package so there we are
that's how you
work with using npm from getting started
with a
setup for a base initialization of your
package going through to creating the
first package
um being able to set up and control the
naming convention for
each of the items within the metadata
that provides the instruction for
the package how you then put in
dependencies such as
express and bootstrap how you can
install them and remove them
and actually use do all this through
command line
if you have any questions please let us
know
so let's kind of jump into the express
js framework
so express.js is a really flexible
node.js and web application framework it
is just something you can
spin up very quickly and build both web
and mobile applications
just a really great tool um you know i
use it all the time for building up my
own applications
um the thing that's so great about it is
it's really simple and so
it's not going to be as have all the the
functionality that you would have in
maybe
a larger scale http service
but with that said it does come with a
lot of functionality that allows you to
not only create websites but you can
also do apis and other routing calls
very very nice so let's go through some
of the
features that express.js have
so as i mentioned before it allows you
to build simple web applications and
that can be either a single
page application or a multi-page
application um it also allows you to
do middleware requests and responses so
for instance if you want to do an api
and have that be part of your middleware
you can actually set that up real
quickly
in fact in the demo that we'll do later
on we'll actually be building out
four different api calls that you'll be
able to do
and you'll be able to see how you can
use express.js for that
um and that then turns allows you to be
able to
see how express.js can help manage some
of
the routing of the different
um http methods and that you'd be using
via url
and then finally it's just a great way
of being able to
dynamically test the work that you are
developing so you can
actually build out a solution and test
it right away and express js
have it in a single packet and then once
you get to a certain point you can then
check in the whole packet
um even have it as part of your
container and then check that into your
main project and then if somebody else
wants to then take on the work they can
then
just pull that in so let's kind of go
step through
you know a basic example so here we
actually have a
full script for creating a simple hello
world
and this includes installing express.js
defining the ports it's going to run on
as well as a basic
piece of code so the first thing you
want to do
is actually go ahead and define how you
want to install
express.js and this is called the very
first variable which is
requiring that express be installed as
part of node packet manager
npm will then pull in the latest version
of express
if you need to define a specific version
of course you can do that
in this example we're just going to pull
the latest one and then we'll go ahead
and with the second line which will then
install express
and when you do it once you'll see how
quickly it installs onto your local
development machine
the next parameters are actually a
callback function so if something
actually happens when you go to
the website where we're going to run our
web application you want something to
pop up and in this instance we'll say
hello world will pop up the
third block is all about where you would
actually go ahead and
host your code and so in this one you'll
see that the
server is going to listen and listen to
port 8081 so that's what that function
actually there
defines and then you can either put in
the a specific host address in the demo
you'll actually see how we define that
for localhost but you can actually then
point this to a production host
environment if you want
and then the final line here is a
command that actually sent
a script to your terminal window
telling you that which port and which
host that you are listening to so let's
see what that would look like
so here we go see have our terminal
window and
we're actually able to then run the
hello world js script that we just
wrote and then once we do that it'll
actually then post
that we have an example app listening at
and here we don't have a web domain
address
and we do have the port 8081
and in our browser window it says hello
world
so that's a quick breakdown of
express.js now let's jump
over and do a demo
so the first thing we want to do to get
express up and running on our system is
we have to have node.js installed so
we're just going to do a google search
to let you know where you can find
node.js
it's actually at nodejs.org so we select
that link
that will take us to nodejs.org and
there are two types of downloads one is
the current download which has
the latest features and then there's a
more stable version that
if you're new to node.js i'd recommend
you to download
next we want to find a text editor and
we're going to go with visual studio
code or vs code as
known it's an open source solution from
microsoft that runs across all the
leading platforms
this will default to our windows
platform but you can run it on mac os
and linux as well
i really like it it's a great code
editor it comes a lot of extensions
and it's open source and next thing you
want to do is because we're going to be
developing apis we want a way to be able
to
visualize those apis quickly and a great
tool is a product called postman
again open source and so you can go out
and go to postman.com
uh top right hand corner you'll see a
bright orange download button where you
can actually go and head and download
and install
postman and that will allow you to be
able to access
all of your apis that we're going to be
creating in express
you can actually use other tools such as
apigee as well for visualizing
your apis but this one's just great to
get you started so let's go ahead and
open
up vs code and we want to go ahead
and open a new folder where we're going
to have our project
we're going to just for our
demonstration here we're going to put
this on the desktop you wouldn't
normally do this but it will work fine
here
i'm going to create a folder i'm going
to title the file the
node express and we'll select that
folder
that now becomes the root folder for our
project in
visual studio we don't really need the
the welcome
screen anymore so we're going to get rid
of that
and one of things that is great about
working with vs code is you can actually
have the terminal window up and running
as well so
let's go ahead and open that so it's
running at the bottom of our screen
and this gives us a little bit of space
and the first thing we want to do is
actually
turn convert the folder in actually into
a
project running node.js so we're going
to use npm
in it and they'll actually initialize
the project we have another video that
explains how to use npm or node package
manager
and you can go ahead and find that um in
our
library here but as we go ahead and we
do that you actually see that it will
create the default package
uh json file which has uh the
name of the folder is the default name
of the package
but you can actually go in and edit any
of these documents
we want to create a default file that's
called index.js
this is where we're going to write most
of our scripts that allow us to
work with node.js
and the first is writing a script that
allows us to install
express and we'll use the node packet
manager
to actually pull and install express
and you can default to specific versions
of express if you want
and we're just going to go with the
latest one so we're just going to put in
express and then we'll go down into
terminal window and say
npm install dash dash save express and
this will install express
so we can actually test out the code
we're working on
and let's take just a moment to install
great thing we're working with node
package manager is that once we finish
with our package here we can actually
wrap it all up and send it over
to any other developer that we're
working with and then you can actually
run the the package and actually have
exactly the same code installed
and there we are we have everything
installed and ready to go
you can see we actually have all of the
modules installed you see that we
actually have express installed as well
and we also want to then make this an
app
and then we'll do app listen
to port 3000 so this is by default we're
going to be running from our local host
which is
uh http server running on this test
machine
and we're going to have express for this
project
run on port 3000
and in the once we actually run the
script we'll actually
post into the console window
a piece of text saying server started on
port 3000
so we're going to go ahead and save this
file a little control
s to save these files
so let's go into localhost in our web
browser so localhost colon
sorry yeah it's localhost column3000 and
you'll see nothing has been reached
that's because we actually haven't done
anything to initialize the script
so we want to come in and we're going to
go nodeindex.js and hit return
and as you can see now we have a message
in our console window
that means that yep there we go we
actually have everything up and running
so we can actually see that the service
is running not a very pleasant message
so let's go ahead and change that
so let's change that to
app get and
require res
and so if you use the get message that's
change what we'll print and we'll type
hello there exclamation mark
and we save that and we refresh the
screen
oh nothing happening yet because we
didn't run the script
let's go back in and we'll run the
script node index.js
and now what you'll see is if we refresh
there we are we have our new
hello there message
all right well let's actually start
building some apis in this
environment so to be able to build the
apis we want to be able to
pull um content so we can actually
create a new file called users.js and
we're going to create
we're going to go ahead and create a a
user's json packet and a jsonpacket is
essentially a an array
um consider it like a small database
and in this array we're going to have
four objects each object is going to
have
three pieces of metadata we have an id
name and email and they'll be id one
two and three and then you'll see that
the names will be
john smith and we'll make up a
couple of others i'm just kind of giving
them arbitrary
email addresses it's just for our
demo here let me grab this copy it
kind of speed up the script writing time
there we go and let's just change what
we need
one of the things that's nice with
working with a visual studio
code vs code is there's lots of plugins
and so
one of the default features is that if
you select
a variable it'll actually look for the
same variable in the script so you can
if you need to you can actually
change them all in once but
we don't need to worry about that right
now we're just creating a
json packet so we have four items
id one two three and four for john smith
and
jack and chris all right so that's
our array string
and we're going to then make sure that
we can export that
as users so we can actually now whenever
we select
the term users in our scripts it'll
actually pull
in this packet all right
looking good
now let's go over to our main index.js
file
and we're just going to go ahead and we
want to like
store where the the api is going to be
so we're going to create
a folder called routes and then a
subfolder called api
and then we'll call a file in there
called users.js
so as we're updating our scripts we know
where to
pull the data from it's just a standard
way of being able to pull out the values
so in here we're going to
say in this instance express is required
for our scripts and we're going to also
say
that router
within express router
correct naming convention
and the script is case sensitive we'll
also
want to create a value later on that
will have a unique id so we're actually
going to
pull in a uuid
package that will actually then allow us
to install
unique identifiers so we use node
package manager to install
uuid again this is a great example of
how
you can go from nothing to something
very quickly
with exp node.js
because we installed express we
installed uuid and
we're off to the races so let's
have users require the path
for where our api is going to be located
all right so let's do a basic get
which will be to pull the record so
we're going to have it
pull all the records so router.get
and we're going to require it to pull
all of the records
in the json packet that we created there
should be
four items to come back
save that looks good
make sure that users is consistent
there's our adjacent packet
and yep everything looking pretty good
all right let's go back to index and
we're going to switch out this function
here from
just a generic get with a generic
statement to actually being able to pull
in the users
so we have to go app
use express.json
dot use
url encoded extended
false
amp dot use
api users so
we're going to be pulling them off in
the same location
require
and where we have our api
scripts okay
and then let's go ahead and open up
postman because we're going to actually
use postman to actually
show us what the results look like
because right now the results
won't show up appropriately um in our
browser window
so postman again is just a api
management tool
if you used apogee or other similar
tools that are on the market mulesoft
you'll see it's very consistent again
this is open source
and what you want to be able to do is
you can actually go and actually go to
the path where the api is stored
and then you can use all the different
types of commands within
your environment to be able to
you know test out the scripts so let's
go ahead and create a
new project new request and we're gonna
go with the default get but there's
actually quite a lot
of different commands we can use and
these are just http commands
and we're gonna type in the request and
in this instance
it's going to be let's run our script
first
script i think we're good
let's make sure we're exporting the data
correctly
okay so we want to run our script so
let's do node
index.js and that will run the changes
that we just created so we can now come
over
to get we select api um localhost
colon3000 slash api
users when we do that brings back
the json package with our for
entry points there
there's all four of them
so that's your first action
now let's kind of get this a little bit
tighter let's actually go in
and see if we can filter by id
so we're going to go in and we're going
to modify our script so it's going to be
route and then we're going to put in the
filter
and in this instance it's going to be id
which would allow us to be able to just
put a
backslash against the end
of the url string we just had and put in
a number or a unique identifier
and then that will actually then allow
us to pull in that unique record
okay that's the data
okay so if found
i'm going to
take the json and print it
so we're going to filter here against
user id
and then publish the results
else if that doesn't work then we'll
just have a
generic error message
we should see this though in the demos
we're creating
this is just good practice
so save that and let's go ahead and
rerun
our node index file against that
folder and now we can actually come in
here and
we do backslash one and that will give
us just one record
and we could change that to 2 or 100 in
this instance and if it's 100
we'll just get a bad request error
message
there's two
all right so that's get
so we've been able to pull all the
records we need to filter against one
specific record against
a specific parameter in this instance it
was id
so let's go ahead and create a new user
so that what we can do for this is we're
going to use the post
command from http to actually push and
post data into
the data source the data sources are
jsonpacket
which means that we'll have to then push
a new record into the json package
using our array statements
because json is just essentially an
array
and so we're going to post and when we
do this we have to create a unique id so
this is where
we have to reference the uid i'm going
to do a v4
unique id which will be
four groups of four so these 16
characters
and then we'll have
name and
email will post
okay looks good
okay so if
new user
input dot name and
new user dot email
and then we want to return the results
okay
okay and so users dot
push so we posted which is http
statement and then pushing into the
the json packet array
okay
okay it's looking good
all right so i think we're good
let's go ahead and rerun our script
nodeindex.js
that allows us to do that so let's go
over to postman so we can actually
connect to
the url i'm going to change the http
statement to
post and get rid of
that go back to users now we just do
this
nothing's gonna happen so we actually
have to go in and we have to update the
body
and this would be the content that will
be passed through and we're
gonna go through with a raw statement
here
and we do json this will be
that's the packet we're sending so let's
go ahead and
the records we want to update we only
have to update two which is one is name
and the second is email
we don't have to do an id because we're
using uuid to generate an automatic one
for us
and we're going to create records for
staff and her email address is steph
gmail.com
yep looking good
okay so let's go ahead and send that
we sent it and if we look at the bottom
we actually now see that we have five
records so a new one's been added
we have our unique id at the top and
then we have
name and email which are the ones that
we just created for staff and staff at
gmail.com
all right so that's posting now the next
thing you want to do
is to update a record so that means we
need to select an id
and then be able to update the content
and for that we're going to use the http
put command so we'll
use id as our way to be able to filter
and then we'll be able to update against
that filter
so construct found
of course users
and then we'll have it
going is user's id
so we know how to get the correct record
and then pass the record back
onto the screen so we know what we're
editing
so if
so we've found
i'm going to update the user
and i'm going to go ahead and pull
information from the body for what will
be updated
and for each
diffuser id
then pass the integer
okay
so this is our values to pass against
the id
and in this instance we'll make sure
that we're updating the values of
username so if we are
updating user and we're just updating
the username we want to
make sure that that's the value that
gets updated
and then we also want to do user email
we don't want to update
the id because it's going to remain
unique and consistent
okay i'm going to make sure that
everything is pushed
to the json package
and then we'll also have a message
saying that
the field has been updated in the json
package
okay
all right so we'll run that script again
and looks good let's go to our folder
let's change the http
post let's put it as get just so we can
see that we have uh
all of the values in the array from the
jsonpacket
and now we want to say put which allows
us to
update just one record
so let's go ahead and select one record
we'll select it1 so
we have one record we can go ahead and
for name we can change this so let's go
ahead and change these
so now you see that the email has
changed so we have staff
as the new account
all right our final api that we're going
to create
is to delete an account and in many ways
it's actually a very basic api because
what we're doing is we're grabbing
the id and then we're saying that all
the associated records with that id
within that row as it were
in the table just to delete the whole
row
and so we want to use again
our id as the
unique value that we're pulling against
so we're going to if users are found
and we're going to filter those users
i'm going to do that filter against user
id
pass that
and they go
and post a message to our
json packet saying user
deleted
no generic message if things fail
okay let's save that and we'll
see we go ahead and we're using we're
just deleting the record now
and we're going to do it by filtering
against
a unique id and then you will then
just eliminate that record
and pass the message that has been the
account has been deleted
okay so save that let's go run our
script
nodeindex.js good
okay has come over here and we're going
to
show that we can pull any of the
accounts so let's just take one of them
one that's good so
let's go ahead and we're going to change
the http command to delete
and we actually have to
select an account so we just do one
when we do that it'll actually delete
that record
and here we are um it says that the user
has been deleted and we now only have
three records in the jsonpacket
and we can pull all the records
and you'll see that there's only three
so being able to pull the records from
adjacent package we'll be able to create
a record
update a record and delete a record
and we can just step through so here's
our json package that we
created originally again this is just an
array it's just a different way of
setting up the array and then we have
our index files which
identifies what are the apps that need
to be installed and where
are the apis going to be serviced out of
and that we're going to be doing this on
the port 3000 and again these are
additional tools that we need to make
sure
um that we have up and running um in our
script and so the first script was to
get all the
um the records seconds to filter against
a
user id for just a specific record
and then for creating a record we
actually went in and we used the uid
tool to create a unique identifier and
then we posted in
the data for the new records we did
something similar with updating the
record we didn't have to update the
user id we just had to update the values
in
the two fields that we needed to be
updated
in this case name and email
and the final step was to go ahead and
delete a record
so these are all apis that you can now
pull into your own application so you
can use them in web applications
or you can actually go ahead and use
them in other
applications such as mobile applications
local applications and other scripts and
this really allows your application to
become more
scalable and more useful
hello and we're going to go through and
do our demo of building a restful api
with node.js so the first thing we want
to do is go ahead and install all the
correct pieces of software
we'll start with node.js so let's do a
google search on node.js
and you'll find that node.js is at
node.js.org so we select that
link and that's going to take us to the
node.js website
and there are two versions of node.js
you can download there's the stable
version and then there's the
latest version i'd go with the stable
version you'll find it available
in windows mac awares and linux as well
and if we go to the next piece of
software you want to go ahead and
install the text editor of your choice
i'm going to use visual studio code vs
code
it's an open source solution it works on
all leading platforms
works really well i like it a lot
microsoft did a good job with this
i also really like it that it's open
source
but there's lots of extensions you can
get for vs code um so it's a great text
editor
and we'll also need postman postman is a
tool that allows us to be able to view
the apis that we're going to create so
let's go ahead
to postman.com and again it's another
uh solution you can download for free
and so we're gonna go ahead and select
the download button
and it will automatically detect which
os you're on so in this case it's gonna
be windows but you can also get mac and
linux as well so we'll go ahead and
download those
and once we have everything installed
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a project in vs code and that's
actually really easy to do all you have
to do
is create a folder
and we do this right off our desktop
and we're going to call the folder node
rest api
and we'll select that folder
and you'll see on the left hand column
that we have
uh the new folder that we created and we
still have the
vs code welcome screen we can get rid of
that we don't need that anymore
so let's go ahead and one of the things
i like with vs code is you can actually
toggle
the terminal window so let's go ahead
and open up the terminal window so we
can actually
run that at the same time and so we're
going to
move our cursor to the folder we just
created and there we are
you can see that and what we're going to
do now is we're going to initialize this
with node package manager
to make this a package and
it's going to go ahead i'm going to ask
for a name we're just going to go with
the default so we're just going to say
yes yes to a couple of these yep enter
enter enter enter
enter enter and it's okay
yep enter all right so now we have
a new file and this is our adjacent
package it has all the defaults in it we
can go in and modify these if you want
to
i have no need to for this exercise but
you may want to for
the solution that you're putting
together
and we're going to create a new file
called index.js
and this is going to be the reference
file that's in the json package
for npm and here we're going to put in
our solutions that we absolutely have to
have
for this to run so we're going to
install express
and express is a web service
application but it's very flexible and
one of the things that we're going to
use it for today is build apis
so in our terminal window we're going to
type npm install
save express this will install express
locally on our machine
and takes a few minutes but it's going
to go and download all the latest
features
this is going to be the latest version
of express you can if you want to
um specify a specific version of
software
for these examples there's no need to do
that
so you'll see that everything has been
installed we expand the node module
we can scroll down and indeed yep there
we are we see express has been installed
along with some other pieces that are
useful
all right so that's our first piece and
the next
is we're going to define our app and our
app is going to
use express
and we want express as a local host on
our local machine
on port 3000 so we've identified port
3000 as the
default port for our application
and
we are going to now create a
an array for some
movies i'm going to have
id title director and release date
exception great movie
and director christopher nolan
and that was released
in 2010 yes 10 years ago
okay so we're going to do and a couple
of items here
and just so that we have some
more than one entry in our array and
array is a javascript you can
think of it as a very simple table
which allows us to have structured data
you can also do a json file you can also
connect to
a database mongodb or something like
that
2019.
okay so we have two movies in our little
array
maybe more than enough right now
a key part is that we have a
consistent structure for the array of id
titled director and release date
and so we're going to create two
apis one is going to be a get api where
we'll get the list
of the items in our api and the second
will be a
post where we'll be actually pushing in
a new item so let's go ahead
and start with the get and what we want
to do is we're going to say
get slash movie and
we are going to have this run as an api
and so what we'll do is we will test
this in a moment
uh this will be running from our web
browser
and actually we'll probably open up
postman and run this through postman
so okay
that pause all the movies
and we'll do a another um get in a
moment where we'll filter by
movie id but let's just get them all for
right now
and we are going to listen
on a server port in this instance it's
going to be port 3000
and we already had defined the port as a
variable earlier
um which um so we're just referencing
the variable and the port number is the
step the
top in line four
just a text string that's going to get
put to the terminal window
and it is going to dynamically
grab the port the value from the
variable from 3000
and place it in our text string easy
and we want to save the file and now
we're going to go ahead and run it so
we're going to do
node index.js
that runs the script and tells us that
we're listening on port 3000 that's
great
that means now that we should be able to
go into postman
and grab
the data from an api so here's postman
if you've not used it before it's a
great tool for being able to manage apis
i strongly encourage you to have a go
with this so we're going to get
the get command and you've done any
applications
web applications you probably use get
and post
for the data that you're
pulling and pushing from forms online
same principle so we want to go ahead
and
we're going to go and i'm going to grab
get i'm going to type in
localhost and it's going to be colon
3000 slash movies
because that's the the name of the
file and we're gonna hit send
and what we get as a response
is the data
in our query
sorry in our array here we go so there's
our array
and the data values have been pulled
back by postman
that's great so now we want to go ahead
and add a movie
to our array
and we're going to do that we're going
to use the
post command and
get and post our http commands
and so we're going to use movies
and in this instance we're going to
push the value into
our list so construction movie
requires we need a structure here
and that structure is going to be
the information that's in there the body
and then we're gonna
push to the log our terminal window
and push so here we're using
push and that's a term in
for arrays within javascript where we
push the data
into the actual array itself
there are lots of ways of being able to
control data within an array
and if you're new to arrays with
javascript i strongly encourage you to
learn more about them there's just an
awful lot you can do with them
and then we want to have a validation
message come up on the screen saying yes
movie has been added to the list so
we'll save what we've just created
and we don't save it it won't show up
and then we're going to re-run
the node index.js file
you can see this we've created here
already
a an api that allows us to pull and push
data
in and out of a variable okay so let's
go back and we're going to change
the header from being get to being push
so we're going to use uh sorry not push
our post so we're going to select
post and then what we want to do is the
value inside of the body and so let's go
over
and we want to select body
and we're playing text and select
json so it's going to be structured and
so
here we will essentially copy the
structure we have here
so let's go ahead and just copy these
elements
and we have to give it an id because we
don't have an auto generated id
so we're going to make this id 3
and then
and it's going to be a number 3
and then we want to put in
title
new movie i'll put in director
[Music]
and we'll have this as
i don't know new director
not very creative here today and then
we need to put in a date so release
underscore date
let's just put in a date
uh today's date will be fine
um just so you know that we're not
formatting the datecon
so let's go ahead and we'll select send
and this will actually go
and we can see boom movies been added to
our list
then we can go back and let's go ahead
and validate that so we're going to
change from post to get
use the same and now we go to
below oh looks like we put an
error in our
formatting so let's go
to
pass the json
and pass it using express and this will
clear up any formatting issues
so app.use express json
express
url encoded extended
false
and this should help us pass our
value
and then we'll rerun that script make
sure you save the previous file
otherwise it won't run the new script
all right looking good so let's go back
and let's go back to
our localhost 3000
movies
and there's only two values here so what
we need to do now is change from get to
post
we'll go to body
and what we're going to do is we want to
have
raw jason and
what we want to do is capture the values
that we have below
and insert
this file into
this new json packet
into our array you can actually just
copy
that it's a little bit cheating but it's
remain same so let's go ahead and
[Music]
get everything consistent
then we'll change the number to three
we're creating a unique title badging
sorry new typo it doesn't need to be
unique just the id needs to be unique
so new movie
director change it to new director
change the date
i'm not doing any formatting on the data
any date
any number really hit save
movie has been added to our list so it's
been added
but now let's go back to get and let's
see if we can actually
see the third entry and scroll down and
there we are we've actually pushed that
json package into our array
so we now have three items in the hoping
added fire our api
okay so
now let's go ahead and search our
movie database i guess we only have
three entries but you know we want to be
able to
so we can do that by using the get
command
and what we'll be doing is we'll be
validating against
a specific id number uh so we have three
and we're going to validate against
just the id number um in this instance
um
the way to do it is through the url so
beforehand we had localhost colin3000
slash movie now we're adding in uh
slash movie slash and then whatever
number of that
will actually filter against the id and
that's essentially what we're doing here
right now
so we're going to go into if movies
dot id again we're using the id value to
actually pull
from our arraylist with my
variables and arrays mixed up here today
and then once we actually have the value
we'll actually post back as a
json packet
and if we have any errors then what
we'll do is we'll throw
up message movie not found so there we
are we're going to pull against an id
and we should be able to then pull that
up
through postman into our terminal window
again the reason why we're using
postpone is that this is actually just
showing
the values going back and forth we're
not having to render a whole web page
it's extremely fast very efficient
all right
so we saved and rerun our script all
right let's go back
and what we're going to do is we're
going to change the value so we're going
to hit
send here we are we see all of our
movies
using the get command now what we're
going to do is we're going to use
a look filter on just id2 which is the
irishman
so do slash 2 and there we are we have
just the information on the irishman so
now you can see how you can create a
simple search
all right
so the final action we want to do is to
delete
a record in our array
and so we can go ahead and do that
and we're going to use the uh delete
command
to actually do that so we'll be able to
push um in a record we've been able to
view records filter guide games records
now we're going to go ahead and do
delete
and so we can do app delete and then
we're going to filter
by specific id number
and when we do this we'll actually then
uh when we put in the url path which
will be localhost calling 3000 slash
movie slash and then the id number so
this is inside that one or two probably
use two
that will then delete from
our array the record for the argument
and save our files i do
have a shortcut and a keyboard drop out
of control plus
s to save files on
windows or command plus s on my mac
and once we've deleted a record we want
to send a message saying that
the movie has been deleted
all right so we want to go ahead
and let's just check our code looking
good
save our file and we want to rerun
the index.js file
yep rerun okay let's go to postman
and grab the delete
so again we're filtering against the
movie id
and then we'll delete that id
okay so we went against the argument
then we hit send and there it is
now we're going to change the command
to delete so we hit
one we'll actually delete conception
movie has been deleted it's great
and let's go ahead and grab our
use get to pull in all the movies
that are listed and it's not going to
find
movie number with their id1 it's not
there anymore
and if we get all the movies
we see we only have one movie and that's
the irishman
and so our delete function has worked
there we are so we've installed express
we're using express to build all of our
applications we have our app running on
port 3000
we are using express to pass the json
effectively back and forth we have a
simple array
that array is then being used to create
an api to pull the details then we're
being able to add a movie
then search for a movie uh filtering
against an id
and then we can actually finally
go ahead and delete a movie
all this using express.js today we're
going to be covering node.js
authentication using jwt or
json web tokens so let's get started
so why are we going to go down this path
so let's cover the key things that
you need to be asking yourself such as
what is a json web token
what is the value of using a json web
token
and then what does the actual structure
of the jwt
look like and then let's go through some
use cases of where you'd actually use
jwts uh both in the enterprise and uh
in the real world and then finally we're
actually going to go through
a demo on how you can actually install a
jwt
using express and node.js
so let's dive into what actually is a
json web token
so a json web token is actually based on
an open standard
it's one that you can actually go ahead
and research and it allows
a definition of a compact self-contained
way
of being able to securely transmit
information between
parties using adjacent object an
adjacent object
is a javascript array and it's very
compact
it's a very tight way of being able to
send data back and forth
the thing that's great about using a
json web token
is that the information itself is
encrypted and it can only be
verified and trusted through a public
private key
pair and we'll get into that about how
you can actually get
to those so you know why would you
actually want to go ahead and use a json
web token are there other formats
that you can use well yes there are
other formats you can use
but what's great about jwt is that it
is a great way to be able to pass data
from
http servers so if you're building a web
application
and you have a web location where you
need to pass
authentication over using a jw2 is a
great way to be able to do that
so for instance you may have a number of
enterprise applications
that run across your cloud environment
you may have some
enterprise applications that run in your
data center
and you want to have people come in such
as your employees or your customers
authenticate once and then be able to
have their id transition from one to the
next
jwt is a great way to do that the
content is extremely secure
and we'll get more into that in a moment
but it is the highest level of security
you can have right now
and the final great thing about working
with jwt
is that the actual tokens themselves are
very well documented and so there's
actually a lot of passes
that you can use so being able to add in
jwt into your application
is very very easy to do which makes it
very easy for you to actually
implement at a large scale
authentication and authorization
and so authorization is a key word there
um that's something that you're probably
coming across
um a lot instead of just being out
identify who you are we want to be able
to authorize what you have
access to so let's have a look at the
structure of a jwt there are
several key elements um the first is the
header and that's actually going to
break down
what kind of token it is by twofold it's
gonna be a gwt token
and what is the signing of algorithm so
sha 512
is a very complex and secure
algorithm and certainly the one that i
would recommend that you use
and you can even go higher than that but
sha-512 is a great place to start
and then you have the payload and the
payload
is the information that's been actually
encrypted within
the web token and so in this instance we
have a name
the admin time type um sub
name um just really you can put whatever
kind of information you want in there
as long as it's applicable um to the uh
service that you're passing the data
into and then you have your
signature which is um encoded header
and payload with the algorithm that
you've sent so in this instance it's
sha 512 algorithm so let's look at some
of the use cases that you'd have
for jwt so a couple of use cases
would be authorization so say for
instance
you have a application and you want to
be able to authorize somebody to have
access to different parts of the
application
jwt is a great way to be able to encrypt
that data and be able to pass that data
back and
forth examples would be jumping from
different parts office 365 and be able
to
have access to different features within
the system
and then another area would be if you're
doing information exchange so
information is being securely exchanged
from one person to another
so a blockchain scenario a multi-um
distributed environment where you want
to be able to have a way to be able to
securely transmit
data back and forth and know that that
data is being encrypted
is another good example so with that
let's take a pivot and we'll go ahead
and we'll look at
uh creating a demo using
our standard stack of node.js and we'll
use
express and postman and these are tools
that you may already be familiar with if
you've seen
other videos that we've created in this
series and we'll go ahead and create
a jwt token
so let's go into our demo of how to
create a jwt
json web token there's going to be some
tools that we need to get started with
node.js is the first so let's go ahead
and find node.js at nodejs.org
and you can either download windows mac
or linux code
obviously you'd install the one that
would be for your operating system
and the next tool that we want to
install is a text editor we're going to
use
visual studio code or vs code go to
code.visualstudio.com
download this this will run on mac
windows and linux
really great text code editor
and then we're also going to use postman
postman is a tool that allows you to
access and view apis that we'll be
creating with express
and you go to postman.com hit download
and again there's versions of postman
for all
leading operating systems and have those
installed and up and running
so we're going to go ahead and let's
open up visual studio code
and we're going to start by creating our
project let's go full screen on this
get rid of the welcome screen and
that's going to open up a folder where
we'll actually have our project
we're going to put this on our desktop
for right now let's go create a new
folder
and we'll call this node jwt
for jason web token select that folder
and we're going to want to go ahead and
use npm
to initialize this folder for
for node and so let's get rid of the
welcome screen again
and let's go ahead and one things i love
about
vs code is going to run the terminal
window right from in here so let's go
ahead and
select npm init or he knows
to pull from the folder that we're in
and
we're just going to select yes here in a
second
for our yep let's go ahead and
create that and you'll see that the
packet has been created
and there is a json packet with just
default information
about the npm package that we created
for node
and we're going to go ahead and create
an index.js file
that's what we'll be pulling from the
package and
the index.js files we're going to
actually rewrite all of our code
and what we want to do right now is
install express
and express is going to be used to
create the apis that we'll be able to
test our jwt against
and then we'll also want to install
a jwt
file so let's call this json web token
and from our terminal window we'll just
go ahead
and install both of those and do that by
typing npm
install save and then we're going to put
express and json web token
express and json web token
and we'll just go ahead and let those
install
only takes a moment for those to get
installed
all right we're up and running okay
so let's go ahead and start bringing in
some of
our apps so we're going to create an
express app
and we're going to use the get http
header
to have everything and go from the
we're going to actually have everything
running on our localhost and we're going
to
run everything off port 3000 we'll do
that in a moment here
but we'll have everything running off a
sub folder called api
it's where our web applications can be
running from
and we'll put in a message that
hey there to show that everything's up
and running
okay and
[Music]
save that
and save you can do control plus s to
save your files
and as you can with a lot of windows
applications and i encourage you to do
that a lot
so let's go ahead and open up postman we
don't even go to our web browser on this
one
and postman
it takes a moment to run the first time
and it comes and postman again is
a tool for being able to manage api
calls and so you don't have to write a
script
so here we are and we can go in here
and we can that's where we're going to
write our script but we have to
do a couple things first let's let's get
everything running so we want to
listen on for port 3000 that's we're
going to run
everything off of
and in the console log we'll actually
throw in a message to confirm that we
are running on uh
everything is up and running we'll just
say okay uh server started on port
3000 again we're going to be running
everything off localhost so you'll be
able to see this
um and this is as you imagine just a
test environment so let's go down into
our console
we'll run this script node index.js to
run the script
it runs really fast not a whole lot
going on there and we're having
everything running off the api
files so let's go and we'll type in
under our get
localhost colon
3000 like slash api
and we hit the there's lots of different
http headers um we can use we're going
to use get for right now
send that and
hey there welcome to the api service
so to be clear this is just an api we're
creating right now this is not jwc
we'll get into that right now
all right so we want to be able to
post data and uh post is actually
pushing data in so we're going to go
into uh going to create a login screens
again
again this is all api so it's not real
but uh look it you get the point
and then just construct a user
and let's go ahead and what we're doing
here is we're creating
a an array
of a random user and then you can have a
name of
id one that they have users can have an
id value which is one
um a username value which is gonna be
john and an
email value of john gmail.com
and then we'll make this a
json web token jwt signing
and they'll have to sign with their user
and this is going to use a secret key
which will be our hash
our hash 512 token
and
respond to the json with the token
okay so let's see now okay and we're
going to
hamp dot and this will be our post
api posts
and what we're going to be able to do is
we're going to jump from one app to
another app and you'll be able to see
how we can move the token with it
and the message will read
post created
all right
so let's just run that script index.js
runs real quick okay
so if we come over here and we go to
posts
and hit send and say
message posts created good
so let's go ahead and try that again and
we want to go to the
login so go from one app to another app
select post and
here in the login
we should be able to request the token
this will be our gwt token
and we hit send we should get our token
and here you can see the the whole token
is encrypted
it's that huge long line
it's very unique
and now we want to be able to go in and
say okay
let's verify
the token so we've gone ahead and we've
created the token but now we need to
as we go from app to app we need to
actually verify the token
so we're going to get an error message
if we don't verify the token correctly
so i'm going to put in a function to
verify
the token
and we're going to create a
bearer header
value which will be
the headers and the authorization for
[Music]
that
and if type of bearer header
i'm going to have it if it's not correct
it'll be undefined
otherwise this part token
will be split
and we're going to require the token
for our very token
else
sense status 403
okay so very token is what we're going
to be calling against
to verify our token i'll show you how
that works in just a moment
and this will be to authorize and to
authorize we'll need to actually
go ahead and
use the token so we can actually put in
here
all right so i think everything's
looking pretty good
oh and if things if we get the error
message means that it's
we'll see the the message forbidden if
we don't put in the code correctly so
let's
double check that everything is looking
good verifying that the token is
required
okay
so if it is then jwt
dot verify and this will
connect our token appropriately
and we'll be able to
put that in as a part of our secret key
and if it is successful
and put in that message there
and we're also going to play in the
authorization data
yep looking good
as you can see a lot of the work is just
making sure that everything
is aligned up correctly
okay so let's run our code nodeindex.js
there we go nice and fast and
we go in and localhost
api posts and change this to
post so this one api which is the api
posts
which is up here
we'll hit send and you can see that we
have
the error code forbidden has come up
which is what we were expecting
because we haven't been able to put in a
secret key
and put in the comment that i've
forbidden
so let's as we're stepping through the
code
and now what we can actually do is we
can go back and we can grab the token
and here is our token below and
we just want the token itself we don't
need the wrappers
and copy that come over here
and if we write again it's going to say
forbidden but
if we go into author into
our headers we can put in
authorization
and then the value
we do bearer and then the key
and once we do this we now get all
of the data that we were asking for
pulled back
which is exactly what we wanted
so you can see here how we can actually
securely
use a jwt to pass values
back and forth across the application
okay and we hit
authorization and we select that and
approve it yep we keep authorizing
so if you don't authorize and you don't
get the data
okay so we have everything against the
api and then we have one application
which is called api post we have another
application called api
plugin and we're able to move the data
back and forth using
our secret key in our jwt
token
and we have everything running on port
3000
of our local host server
and that's our demo so first of all
let's cover why you'd want to go through
this tutorial so we're going to cover
what my sql is we're also going to tell
you how we're going to connect with
node.js
and why you'd want to do that with mysql
and then finally we're going to do a
demo taking you through all the steps on
how you can actually do
that kind of connection so what is my
sequel well
basically my sequel is probably the
world's
most popular relational database and so
if you think of relational databases
that are table driven mysql is arguably
the most popular
database out there for rdbs systems
it is by far the most popular open
source
uh relational database the entire
database is written in c and c
plus plus it's been around for a really
long time
and again it's open source which is
great
which means that there are no licenses
or costs for actually using my sequel
and you'll find that companies of all
sizes from
small mom-and-pop shops all the way up
to massive
enterprise global enterprises are all
using my sequel
so you know why would you want to then
take that next step
of connecting node.js with mysql well
fundamentally comes down to the basics
of the differences between the two
products
mysql is a database and node.js is a
architecture framework for building out
web applications
again with mysql it's open source
it's free to use you don't have to pay
anything
there are no licenses which if you
compare it with other solutions out
there
is a big deal my sequel even though it
is open source
it's incredibly powerful it's one of the
more mature
open source programs out there i think
apache is probably
arguably more apache our web server is
probably
more mature but uh my sequel is very
close behind it
so it has had a huge amount of
investment this is not a solution
that's only a couple years old we're
talking about a solution that's
more than 15 years old very very
structured very powerful
and you can do a lot of really good
things with it
you can actually then build solutions
with it and using php
java really any kind of database
um even other systems and other
frameworks will allow you to interact
with mysql
and it just allows you to work with just
huge amounts of data very very quickly
so let's go through a demo of how you'd
actually use node.js and mysql
so i'm going to go ahead and we're going
to get started by
putting our environment together so
let's start by selecting node.js and
downloading it so go to nodejs.org
and there you have your options for
windows mac or if you want to go for the
source code
you can go ahead and download and
install that
the next is to install zap and so i'm
going to go to
zap installers for a quick search and
it's on our apache friends.org site
and here we have example windows linux
and
mac os 10.
and then finally we want to go ahead
and install visual studio so visual
studio is going to be
our ide our integrated development
environment in this instance we're going
to use visual student code if you don't
use visual studio code
it's a great free open source solution
for being able to build applications
i'm a big fan of it so i encourage you
to use it
and go ahead and download install that
and we have visual studio um code up and
running so
go ahead and we can open up a new folder
and let's go ahead and create a new
folder and just put a stratified desktop
here
and it's just for uh kicks and giggles
so i'm just gonna type in
nodemysql for our source code and
open up that folder and select that
and so we now have this folder selected
in our visual studio code editor
and what we want to do is we want to get
rid of the welcome page and we don't
really need that anymore
and we're going to terminal window so
we're going to see
the script that we're writing we'll be
using tunnel quite a bit
um in this so for instance we're just
going to test that we have npm installed
we do so that's great
and we're going to go npm init and
that's actually going to set up our own
node package module and we can actually
see that the
json file for that package has been
created so we go in there we can see
that all the defaults
selected now you'll see that index.js is
the default
file that we created so we're going to
go ahead and
we're going to create our own index.js
file and we're going to add
in some instructions into that file to
actually
install the correct software from the
npn package
and the first thing we want to do is
install express
which is a package that's great for
building uh
lightweight web applications not mobile
applications i suppose if you're doing a
responsive design
but in this it's really it's a web
application environment so we're going
to
put in the requirements for that and
then we're going to
also go and require that my sql gets
installed
and you'll see that for both of them
we're just going to use npm's default
commands for
creating it and we'll go down to the
terminal window and we'll do npm install
and it's going to install the
express and my sql environment
and as that installs you actually see on
the left hand side
under uh the folder you actually see
the files starting to be installed uh so
for instance we have the node modules
and underneath that will be all the
subsequent files that we need
and there we are everything is installed
all right so let's go ahead and validate
some of these clients make sure
that everything is installed so we're
going to open up zamp which allows us to
go in
and view and see
that everything's stored so we have my
sequencer we have apache installed
we can start to stop under services
with zam go ahead and do that you can do
this through telewindow as well but
the ui interface is really nice so let's
go into
my sql um interface
and you'll see that we don't have any
databases these are all just
the standard test databases and so we
have to go ahead and create one
and so let's get our
sql database connection created
so i'm going to write const db
equals my sql create connection
and we want to create connect to the
localhost in this instance
and user is just going to be a root user
account
which is the standard user account that
comes from my sql uh there is no
password for
the root user when you're running it
locally or i encourage you to change
that as quickly as you can because you
really want to have
a password free environment
and now we want to be able to then
connect to the my sql
environment
so do real write db dot connect
uh parenthesis error and we want to
throw an error message if
the connection isn't good so if we do
error
we'll throw the error message
to the log window
and if we don't then we'll write
mysql connected
all right
and now we want to connect that to our
express app
the next step we want to do after we
made our connection
is to go ahead and create a database so
we'll do
both steps at the same one so writing
the script right now and then we'll
run the commands in the terminal window
so we can actually create a database
and so we're going to go ahead and we
want to create um a database
and let's write let's sql equals
create database
i'm going to call the database node
mysql you could call it whatever you
want
um but this is just a node my sql
script db
query
sql
through error message
rest.send
database created
so we'll throw a message saying that
database has been created
let's go save that to demonstrate that
we've connected
and we've created this so let's go ahead
and we'll do node index.js
to run that and we'll connect it to my
sql that's great
good first step and then we'll go to
window
i will go to localhost 3000 which is
the default connection but
what you'll see is that we've actually
created the name of the database has
been changed to node by sql so we've got
an error message which we expected
and so what we're going to do is we're
actually going to go ahead
and we're going to say we want to listen
and if the error message if comes up to
3000
then
in the console window we want to
put a message of service started on
porsche 3000
so let's try that again
node.index.js yep and server has time
for 3 000
let me refresh that i'm still getting an
error message
and what we want to see is let's
go ahead and see how database hasn't
been created
so let's go and connect to
database and database
let's go ahead and click create db
on port 3000 all right so by doing that
we write that command
and that function and that goes and
creates our database and we'll actually
see
what we have now node mysql has been
created
great first start now we have to go in
and create some tables we have no tables
in here
all right so let's go down let's go
ahead and create a table
so what you're seeing right now is that
we're using
the index.js environment within a
package on node.js to actually
create and control everything that we
want to see in our windows
so all of the work that we're doing for
creating a table for creating the
database
for initializing the core files it's all
being done through js
and so here we are going to create a new
table and call it
creating it's going to be called the
employee table
and so once we run the command create
employee it's going to create a table
has the employee fields which is going
to have an
id which will be an integer that will go
into auto increment
they'll have a name field and we'll also
put in a designation field
and i will have a primary key as well
keep it very simple right now
and let's just put our db connection
so that everything connects effectively
okay so everything goes correctly then
we'll have the message employee table
created so let's test this out
and node.xjs
make sure that the data we have now
actually a database field that we can
connect to
so we've got nodemysql so we're
connecting to the correct database
obviously we get an error
and then we'll try that again yeah okay
database
so database has the name
and because but noted my sequel there's
no fields in there yet
so let's go ahead and
put in create employee fields and let's
run the
function that creates the new table and
then
voila we have a new table
and so the next action we want to do is
actually
populate the table with a record
so this starts becoming familiar so
we're not going to
put in a single record we'll call it
employee one for right now
and we'll write the
the function in an empty one and
when we run that function uh it'll
actually go ahead and
create the lit insert the record into my
sql
and then the name will be jake smith
and the designation will be
a chief executive officer
certainly encourage you to put your own
self name your own name into this
make yourself your own ceo because why
not
and we're going to make this as an
insert record
i'm going to insert into the employee
table i'm just using some basic sql
scripting here
and what you'll see actually with visual
studio code is that
it's actually providing a lot of prompts
to make it easier to write your code
microsoft is looking to actually add
some ai
to visual studio code to actually start
auto completing
script which will make it even easier to
write your
code all right so let's go run node
index.js
we've seen everything connected and
we'll grab the
function employee one and let's go over
to our express site let's just go and
we'll insert the command employee one
employee has been added and we will just
validate this by going back to my sql
and we'll refresh it and you'll see
we click on the employee tables we
should now have an employee in there
yep there we go jake smith
hold on jake first record
all right so we want to be able to now
select the employee
so let's go ahead and do that
and we want to be able to easily get the
employee list
so let's use our sql command and
do select start which is everything
from the employee table so we're
actually playing everything from the
employee table
i'm going to query the database
let's throw a message to confirm that
the query
is successful
we'll put everything in the console log
results
all right let's give this a whirl
okay so let's go and run our command
or localhost 3000
but get employee
and this guy's employee details fetch
now we go to the console window in
visual studio yep there we go we have
now all the
packet information including the id
about
jake smith
okay so let's go ahead and see if we can
actually update the employee information
so as you can see now we're starting to
run into just our
standard sql commands and so we want to
be able to update the employee from a
browser
and as you can tell we're not using any
forms or any other
types of records we're just simply
interacting
with between the the browser the server
and the database
and the new name will be updated name
and just make sure we're updating your
program code
now we'll show that we're matching
against id1
all right so that's wrong
[Music]
and
[Music]
jake smith is there now go
and select
jason quality colon
same slash one we've now gone ahead
and updated
the jig jigsmith information
so let's click on play table and we now
see he says updated name i know not very
creative but
it allows you to see a change
and finally we can go ahead and delete
the record as well
so it's going to be similar to update
but i'm deleting instead
we're going to delete
the record from the employee table
there's
[Music]
[Music]
and
and then we want to be able to show that
the record has been
deleted
[Music]
okay
[Music]
deleted and we go to uh
database we mean that gc
on the employee table that there are no
entries
the one on the record that was there has
been deleted
and so this shows you how you can very
easily control everything
from using your connection into
my sql right from node package manager
you can create a table you can select
your records
you can then update any record that you
selected
and finally you can delete any record
that
you want to be able to delete
so what we're going to do is um so
what's in it for you
so in this uh presentation we're going
to go through
three key things you know what is
mongodb
how do you connect to mongodb with
node.js
and mongodb is part of the mern stack so
we're going to
cover what the mer stack is and how it
applies to node.js
so what is mongodb so mongodb
is a it's a probably the most popular
nosql database out there it's
cross-platform
and very easy to scale it's available
on all cloud systems you can also run it
locally which is what we'll be doing
later on in our demo
but it's just a very flexible database
environment for
modern applications it works on the
concept of
collection and documents
what you'll find is uh mongodb was
originally written in c
plus plus and it is what's referred to
as a nosql database so this is different
to a relational database which is built
up of tables with rows and columns
this is a nosql database as simply a lot
faster and more powerful for the work
that you're doing
and you're able to use mongodb very easy
you can actually go ahead and download
it we'll actually do that as part of our
demo
so you know why connect node.js with
mongodb
well the reason why you want to do this
is that
mongodb is a modern database
it's not restricted by the the the
challenges of scalability that
all the uh relational databases have
it's really designed for
uh building mobile applications and
websites
that scale into the millions and
millions of users
so mongodb probably the most important
feature is scalability the performance
of the database is
phenomenal and it is
extremely highly available for the
solutions that you'll be creating so
when you push it
out your solution to the cloud you can
almost guarantee it's always going to be
running
you also have the ability to be able to
scale to very
large complex multi-site solutions in
fact one of the very first
mongodb applications i built was a
multi-tenant environment and it just
worked really well and you'll be able to
easily deploy your solutions across
microsoft azure aws google cloud
uh et cetera so you know why do you want
to keep connecting to mongodb and
i think probably one of the other areas
that
probably is often forgotten with manga
it's just the concept around
big data and you can i mean when you
talk about big data
and you're talking about absolutely
massive massive
databases and mongodb
is front and center for all of that you
can do your
effective content management and
delivery um
it has an effective mobile and social
infrastructure so
um by that it allows you to be able to
build out solutions
that can go to all modern day types of
applications
and the data is actually very easy to
manage
through your central data hub and then
finally being able to connect to mongodb
is very easy particularly as there is a
client
called mongoose that makes the
connections extremely easy
so you know finally let's kind of look
into how
[ __ ] db is part of the mern
stag so manstak is a
javascript stack and it's of javascript
solutions
that are built for modern single page
applications
and there are four key solutions in the
merge stack there's
mongodb which is your database express
which is your
server side http environment
react which is the solution for being
able to
create your solutions on the client and
the
node.js which actually manages the whole
environment it's really an environment
that's
designed to make it very easy to be able
to build
out modern day solutions so mongodb
is the m in moon express is the e
react is the r and node j
s is the n so again
as you start working with some of our
other videos that we have
here you'll be able to see how all of
these tools
really complement each other so we've
done an introduction
on uh [ __ ] db really the best thing
now is to get you out you know your
hands dirty by actually doing a demo so
we're going to go through a demo
what i would strongly encourage you
however though is that
this demo really does build on a lot
of the other videos that we've done in
this series uh so
you really do want to spend some time on
the node.js
video the node.js for express video
the node.js for apis video
really all of those videos help
complement the work that you'll be
doing with this video here you'll see
some real strong correlations plus a lot
of new content as well so with that
we're going to jump into
the demo so let's do our demonstration
on how to use mongodb
with node.js first thing we want to do
is go ahead and install node.js so
you're going to go and do
google search node.js and that should
bring up a result of going to nodejs.org
and here you can download node.js for
multiple platforms
so windows linux mac os
they're all supported you can also get
the original source code and recompile
your version of node.js if you want to
now we're just going to install the
windows version
and the next thing you want to do is
install your favorite
uh text editor i'm going to install
visual studio code vs code
it runs on all leading platforms mac os
windows and linux
it is open source you can edit it and i
like it because you can do an
awful lot with it just a lot of
extensions and it's just a great tool
all around
so that's the next thing you want to
install
and then we want to go ahead and we want
to go to
mongodb.com so we can install
the [ __ ] db database so you want to go
to
software community server
and you want to then select the
mongodb community server
uh which platform you want
and where it's going to connect with
and you want to select the download
to install that and that'll take a
moment or two for you to download and
get that up and running
once you've done that we want to go
ahead and we're going to open up vs code
so we can start
editing and the code that we need for
our new
solution so let's go ahead and create a
folder
uh off our desktop that we'll use for
mongodb so i already have a folder
created called demo i'm just going to
select that
and then inside there i'm going to put
in a node
[ __ ] db and select that folder
and that's going to open up vs code
and it's going to have our folder in
here so we're going to get rid of the
welcome screen we don't need that
um we do want to however open up our
terminal window so we're going to
uh run that that's one of the things
that i really like about vs code is you
can actually have
your terminal window or command line
window actually
inside the development environment
you're working at so you don't have to
be jumping
from one solution to another and then
we're going to initialize
our package so npm in it for the folder
that we're in
it's going to create our node package
manager it's going to create our
default package and we're going to hit
return that's going to go ahead and
start the process
and we're just going to go with the
default um
settings that npm is going to give so
just hit return return return
a few times and that will get up and
running for you
and our entry point for the application
is going to be index.js
area that's uh js package and there we
have
everything this is just the uh
the the json package that provides the
instructions that npm would use
to pass the um the program now you
notice that we have index.js as our
leading file so we actually have to add
a new file here and we're just going to
tour this one
index.js so we actually have a file that
can be referenced
and now we're going to go ahead and
we're going to actually put in
our default application so express is
going to be required
so we're going to make sure that that is
included in our first line of our
instructions
and then we're also going to
have a path that's required
and we're going to require handlebars
and these are all part of our express
environment
and don't forget to save your file as
you're going along and we're also going
to have
express phbs
and this is going to be our express
handlebars
and we're all going to
allow insecure
prototype access
you wouldn't normally do this but uh
because we're running everything locally
it just makes it easier for
you to actually get all the code in
and then we're also going to add in
our body parser
and these are all the required solutions
that we need
to be installed when you're running this
package
and so let's save the file and then
let's go ahead and
run it so we're going to do mpn install
and we do
save and this will install express
and we also have install path
uh handlebars
express handlebars
and
[Music]
and this is where we'll install
prototyping
and we'll also have the body parser
[Music]
installed and we're just going to run
that
this will just take a moment or two to
install
all right there we go so we have
everything installed which allows us to
now start working with our scripts
so we're going to create an app in
express
and we're going to listen on port 3000
and we're going to have a message then
go to our console log
and we have everything running off our
local port on
local host on port 3000 so let's go and
we're going to select node index.js
and shows us everything's running
which is good we can actually test this
in our web browser if we wanted to
okay so let's start working on our app
so our app is going to
use bodyparser
and we're going to encode
our request
and the goal here is we're going to
create a file that's going to go back
and forth
to mongo's among uh to
mongodb
so body parts is going to use json to
encrypt
the content
and we're going to do a get command to
get our results
and if we worked if you've seen the api
video then we did that here in fact
it's probably a good idea to actually
sit down and look through some of the
other videos that we've created such as
the json sorry the node.js
node.js for express node.js
for apis and node.js for authentication
before doing this video
we're going to create a default page
and it's going to say welcome to the
students database
the principles that we're putting down
here you'll be able to apply
to any solution that you're creating
with mongodb
and so we want to have a simple action
that we're going to put on here which is
going to be
click to gain access
okay we're going to put in the path and
where to get the list
from
okay
all right so here is a basic web page
that we're creating
nothing fancy
but it's going to take you to a place
where you can actually get all the
content
now what we're going to do is we're
actually going to go and
pull the content from manga
so run this and we can open up web
browser you'll see what it looks like
let's just go to localhost close out
these
other tabs don't need them localhost
3000
and there we see welcome to the student
database click on the database
and you click on if we click on it now
nothing will happen so yeah nothing
there
so let's make something happen okay
all right so let's begin extending our
app so what we're going to do is we want
to
set the views
i'm going to do a join
directory name
and app
engine so let's go for our views we
haven't have engine yet but let's go
ahead and
create a new folder let me call that one
views
and let's expand that
actually that should be okay
hps
express handlebars
and we're going to allow prototype
access for
express enterprise
so with express handlebars if this is
new to you
it allows you to separate your content
from your layout
which if you have developed with
swift for a mobile application on the
mac
using xcode is the same principle there
but for
a web application
so we're just putting out here
some of our default environment
settings
i'm going to set our view engine
for handlebars
yeah just checking through our code it's
looking good
okay so that provides that so let's
create a new folder under our views
and this one we're going to call layouts
so again this is where we
are splitting our layouts
and we're going to have a folder called
models at the root of our application
and under models
we're going to put in db.js so the dbjs
file is going to be where we put our
instructions
for our database and so here we're going
to go ahead and we're going to
require to import mongoose a mongoose is
a
tool in node.js that allows you to
connect
to mongodb
we're going to require the use of
mongoose and so we're going to do npm
install dash say save mongoose
and that's going to run and install our
local machine so we can actually
test this out
and once we've got this installed what
we're going to do is we're going to
start connecting
to a database that we're going to call
student db
okay we're already already installed so
let's go mongoose.connect
and we're going to call it
mongodb
and we're going to run this off our
local host
so we installed the community version
that has just run out of our logo host
and it's going to run from the port
27017
i'm going to call this one studentdb
so again with our application we're
splitting out
all the functionality so if you want to
reuse elements you can
so we're going to have a new a user and
url
parser
then we'll make sure we capture
everything correctly
okay so if arrow then we'll send a
message to the console log
and we have either connection successful
or
things go wrong error in connection
and then if there is an error then what
we'll do is we'll have the error message
posted
okay
and then we're going to do require
[Music]
student dot
model so this will actually call the
model we're going to create
and so what we need to do now is
creating
under models we're going to create
student of model
dot js and this is where we're going to
do
our instructions for our student model
so
first thing you want to do is we want to
import
mongoose express and the student model
so we've got here let's make sure we
have everything let's capture that
so let's go over to our student model
all right so let's make sure that we
have everything so we want to have
mongoose
and
[Music]
i'm going to create a new variable
called student schema this will allow us
to structure
what our model will look like this will
be a
a new
new schema in
using mongoose
and our new schemer is going to be full
name
and we're going to break down our
jsons package so we're going to
put in the instructions for what the
schema would look like so
we have the type we have been required
this field is required
and the second value is going to be
email
type string
this field is required
that's the message error message you
want to send if
the field isn't filled out
mobile phone number this will be just a
number
and we're going to have city
and this type will be let's just make
this a string we're just going to try
and keep this simple for right now
the tilde is required
all right so here's our schema
looking pretty good right mongoose
dot model
and connect this to our
student model so we want to go ahead and
save that
okay okay a new folder and this new
folder is going to be called
controllers
and we have a new file under controllers
and that new file is going to be called
studentcontroller.js
let's go in and see what we're going to
add here
so we want to import make sure we're
running express
so express is required for our
controller
we also want to set up a variable for
router so writer express.router
and we want to make sure we're also
connecting with mongoose
so we have a connection to our mongodb
and we also want to make sure that we
have
connection to our student model
so humongous mongoose dot model
and our student model and this allows us
to make sure that we have
this student model pulled over
effectively
for our controller for our student
controller
okay so let's go to router get
i'm going to render this
and student slash add or edit
we'll come into that in just a moment
so we want to be able to view title
and this will pull in the insert
student
i'm going to use under our views
we're going to create a new folder
and this one's going to be called
student
and we're going to create a new file and
this one will be
add or edit dot js
oh hps sorry for our handlebar
so you notice we don't have to put the
file extension
uh node.js manages all that for us
so router dot post
so this will be our we're going to get
our
content and then we're also going to
post content so the post will go back
as part of our body and there'll be an
id
so we want to then instead insert the
record that we'll be creating
so again if you've been if you've worked
through
the node.js api
video then you'll start seeing that
there's some commonalities here
of being able to insert or update a
record
and we actually cover that using just a
sample json package this really takes it
to that next level
okay okay
so we want to put in a new student
record this will be
student and we're going to have that
full name
is going to come from our body
and we're going to also capture the
email
essentially we're going to follow the
model that we created
and mobile phone finally with
a student city
and then we want to save the record that
we create
okay
all right so we're going to manage our
error message
and we're going to put in similar
messages that we've put in before
so we want to redirect to our student
list
and we're going to go ahead and create
that in a moment
so let's create a new file student
list.hps
so list.hvs
and here so what we do is with tuned
list that's actually going to match then
the uh controls for being able to
display the records in the database
and then we'll put um a
message if there's an error then you
know we'll put an error message there
and
ask you to report the error message
we're going to try and not do that
all right so now the next step we need
to go through
is we want to call a function to update
the record
and let's go ahead and we're going to
update our records
and we do the student.find1 and update
command
okay
okay so we will redirect to our student
list as
needed if not we'll throw an error
message to our console load
yeah looking good
and again this is just an example but
something that you'll be able to do
yourself
i have with it your own solution
and then we want to like go back
to our list to then render
the records
all right and here we want to put
student and then
how we're going to find the record
[Music]
we'll throw a error message to our
console log
so as you can see we always throw an
error message to the console log
error messages are really useful
okay all right looks good
save that
okay let's do another router and this is
two we're gonna do the router against id
so allow us to get the content
so we are to get information by id of
the student
and what you can see is there's a lot of
the work we're doing here
is very repetitive um and
you'll find as you create more modular
code that
it makes easier for you to write your
code and update and manage your code
okay so we're going to get our
view title we're going to put that into
our document
okay
all right so our next router
is
we want to be able to delete a record by
id
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to find our records our student
record we're going to
find it by id and then we'll do
find by find id and remove
okay so we're gonna to once we've
removed your record we're gonna redirect
to our
list so we can show our student list
and otherwise we'll send an error
message to our console log
okay so i think we have
what we need maybe there's maybe there's
one more
thing i think we need to do it i think
this is
good
okay so let's go to our
layouts add a new file there we're going
to call this one
main layout
dot hbs
and here we're going to put the skeleton
of
our web page together
let's write this out so i'm going to put
in
html code
and
[Music]
we're just going to keep this real
simple
header we want a title
and this is going to be students
database
i'm going to maybe just call students
so we now go to
[Music]
we'll try and find out bootstrap for
we're going to just grab that
and we're going to use bootstrap
to get started and there are a couple of
components there's a css component and
then there's the javascript component so
let's just go copy the
css component
and then we're going to just link that
into the header section of our
web page so
and then here's an example of different
components you can create
uh if you're not used if you haven't
used bootstrap before it's an open
source
framework originally developed by
twitter great
tool so in our header
we want to put in the link to the css
there's that
and
now i need to also
put in our own styles
so we've got here some styles that we
created earlier on
um for the work that we're doing
you can just paste those in so we have a
box style that we want to use
that will extend the box style that you
get
with bootstrap
all right so we're going to start
working on our body content
plus bg info and so this is actually bg
info is
a css class file from bootstrap that you
can use
and you know the id of box
and again we're going to do
another class which allows us
for our table structure
so a little bit of knowledge of
bootstrap is great here
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to put in the content
which we're going to call body and this
will show up on the screen
so again we're pulling from records
within bootstrap
dick through bootstraps lots of content
there for you to be able to take
advantage of
okay
so now we want to be able to add or edit
our record
view title
and the um
the the the french brackets allow you
to be able to pull records and content
directly from
the code that we're writing
so we're pulling title from insert
record and it's part of our
router command
and then we'll put in our form
which will be student post
i'm just gonna do a basic form here
nothing fancy
we will put in the first
record will be a hidden field and this
will be for id
so we want to auto generate the id we
don't want to have somebody put that in
and then we will put in
[Music]
our form elements
so we'll have first will be the label
it'll be full name
be an input field
this will be text in the input field
and again we're using form dash control
which is from
bootstrap css and we'll have
a full name
and placeholder before name so where we
have name there
will actually match up with
the value that we're putting in our
model so here we have student
full name
so we're matching everything up to the
model that we created
okay so let's do this for our
remaining form elements
and again as you see we can put this
together really quickly
so i'm going to put in for as well the
email
and then we'll do mobile and city
and here we keep going
and form groups
yeah we'll be able to have the type of
tool for putting in mobile
so as you can see because we're using
just standard
html here you can actually reference
external libraries
such as uh javascript libraries for
uh formatting the field that you're in
regular expressions
things like that
and let's put in our final value
which will be for city
and normally when i'd be writing this by
hand
i would actually be copying pasting
sections of code and just changing the
values as necessary
just to make it easier on myself but
here i'm just typing out everything for
you so you can
see the whole process
okay all right so there are our values
of course remember save your files as
you're going along
everything looks good
and we're matching up our values
with our records
and we will have a button that allows
you to submit
you also want to have a button to select
view all if you want to be able to view
all the records okay
looking good
okay let's go back over to list now we
want to be able to
pull our records so this will display
the list of students
in a table
[Music]
right let's go ahead and
format that table
so we're going to put together our
format here
but then we're also going to add buttons
at the bottom so we can actually add a
record to the database or if we want to
add or delete a particular record from
the database
i'm going to call this one
create a new student record for student
list
i'm just going to type all this in for
you
and you'll see how we put placeholders
for the values as we put them in
these are our table headers
okay body content
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to add in
[Music]
an element that allows you to create a
row for each
item listed so if you have two or more
items
they'll appear as an individual row
on here and again what we're doing is
we're pulling in
the values to be able to
pull from the model that we created
earlier on
so this being the data that's been
submitted
so we have it put in the value for the
email
full name and mobile and city
we're not going to show id
so it's pulling out all of this data
that we created earlier on
so we have everything posted into our
list
as documents
so let's go into a hps file and
it's our list let's bring our
file entry here this will be for
city
then this is just a
placeholder at the end
of the list
oh yeah you know we're going to do is we
can add in
reference for the id
so we want to edit the document we can
and then we want to do the same thing if
we want to delete the document
so each route calls
student and then
just delete
now delete based on the id
there we go passing that
instruction over
so click
[Music]
simple
i'm going to ask him are you sure you
want to
delete if somebody clicks on the record
they hit cancel then won't get deleted
if they hit
okay then it will get deleted
this is why you can actually write js in
line
okay
and then we want to close out
where the row will end so how
each opens and closes the record
i'm just tying up some of the html there
save that
okay looking good back to our
root index file so
see now we want to
also require
our model
and then
we'll have our student controller
also be a require
of where it's going to pull the student
controller from
okay
and this is just the instructions on
where we can actually find
the content okay it looks good so
let's do node next js everything's saved
we're going to rerun
everything
and we got an error
let's go check out where our error came
from
so let's go in to our files
this is one that we created so
error is in
[Music]
stream controller see where's the error
oh we need to
have our module we need to export our
module to our router
all right let's go open up [ __ ]
database
and we can just start seeing where the
records are
it's just installing the latest updates
here
so we need to go ahead and in our
connection string so it's on localhost
that's the port let's just double check
that make sure we're
completely aligned so here's our
database connection
and there's our port and student
database
and we did this with one go to mongoose
for connecting to [ __ ]
so i'm going to connect and here are
where our records are being stored
so we're going to create a database and
we're going to call this database
it's going to be called studentdb
studentdb sbk sbk sensitive
and my collection name is students
let's go ahead and create a database so
there yeah there's our database
and let's go
we run our index js file
and everything was successful
this is good
all right so
everything should have passed
successfully good good good database
connection is good
so let's go to localhost
and here we are so we can start actually
navigating through our application
so we see we have our setup we have no
records so let's go ahead and create one
and we go through you can actually start
stepping through
the different layouts that you've
created so here's our layers a
separate to our code
so there's some spacing we probably need
to add that let's go ahead and just add
that
and let's rerun our code
this is the fun bits where you know
everything is
just tidying up okay so you know it puts
in one line one space
because we didn't put in the actual html
code between multiple spaces
so we're going to go in and select
insert
so let's put in uh
smith and we'll do smith at
gmail.com and let's just put in a
random phone number
there we go we don't have any formatting
so we can put anything in there
and the city uh i know where am i
um this i'm in delhi so submit that
hit submit and it takes us to a list and
voila
we actually have a list with a record in
now if we go back to our database we can
actually refresh it
and now we actually start seeing our
records being created
and we see the id is automatically
created and there's our
records okay let's go back
and now we can select edit we can edit
the record
so let's change our city to bangalore
hit submit all right city is now
bangalore
and if we want to we can add it again
and so this is pulling in
yeah if we do a delete it's going to
ask us do we want to delete
okay
a little bit of formatting applying
there
and the records are all good so we can't
make that smith jones
but because you need to hit submit
wouldn't update the record
so we hit submit adoptee it's the record
we hit delete it's going to say are you
sure we say yes we are
and it has
congrats that record okay so let's go
back about code
and because we have everything separated
and actually now just go to our student
controller
and we'll find our delete you guys
delete
and we had a
uh you had a couple of minor errors
there
it's where it's good to test out your
code
okay let's run that again
and refresh everything
so we'll go to our database we're going
to create a new entry
let's call this one some john gmail.com
we'll put in a phone number you see that
the formatting is just playing from
um our
uh bootstrap so there we are there's
john do you want to delete they say yes
yeah easy there we go also and we hit
refresh the record should be gone yep
it is and so we've created an
application
where we can update applications we can
create an application we can list all
the items
and we did all of this using
just open source solutions through
node.js and that was
with using express some of the
components come with express
uh mongodb for our database and then
mongoose to connect to our database
we're going to be going through some of
the simple questions that you would be
asked
during a node.js interview let's just
get started
so the first question you're probably
going to be asked is you know you know
what is node.js you know do you know
what it's for
and essentially node.js is one of the
most popular if not the most popular
uh open source cross-platform javascript
programs
it allows you to build out web
applications that
run on the server it's extremely
flexible it allows you
to implement a lot of solutions outside
of just
the core programming runtime and allows
you to build solutions
extremely quickly in an open source
mindset
for devops it is used essentially for
creating client size web applications
we'll see this later on and you may want
to talk a little bit about
using express js and how you can build
out apis
to work with node.js and connecting to
databases such as mongodb
and that is also really good for being
able to
store data intensive applications
that are asynchronous and event driven
in their
model and this is important when you're
talking about
creating applications that can scale
rapidly
so you're gonna then us be asking you
how does nodejs work well
node.js itself is actually built on the
v8
engine and the v8 javascript engine is
the same engine that runs javascript
in your chrome web browser extremely
fast
it allows for high output and
non-blocking
out through your i o input outputs and
is a single threaded event loop
so you're going to be then asked you
know where can you use node.js
and and the reality is the applications
for node.js
keep expanding but there are some core
applications that you can work with
node.js right now
so such as web applications distributed
system and network applications
probably referencing the web
applications is a really good starting
point
because here you can actually talk about
maybe some examples that you've done
where you're building out some of these
web applications
indeed one of the things that you want
to be consistently doing
and peppering your answers with is
examples of work that you have done
now it doesn't matter if those examples
are purely experimental or
training examples that you've done the
fact that you've actually worked with
node.js
and created a distributed system or a
web application
is really valuable because it shows that
the person that you're meeting with
that you have knowledge and
understanding and practical experience
of applying the theory of working with
new js
with the practice of working with
node.js
so be asked about you know essentially
the i o
refers to the transfer of data in and
out
of uh a system and that's really it you
know
there's a reason why google calls their
conference io it's the transfer of data
in and out of our brains at that
conference
the application is same here it's about
moving data in and out
of systems through using node.js
and that every um event can be tracked
whether it's on a physical device or
network or files within a system again
it's input and output so let's go
through and
you know you're going to be asked yo can
you explain the difference between front
end and back end development
and this is a question that i can ask a
lot
when i'm meeting with clients um you
know people get really
confused about what is the difference
between front-end and back-end
development
bottom line front-end is what gets
resolved
inside of your web browser or the app on
your
mobile device back end is what gets
resolved
um essentially um what we call the the
back office
or server side applications but it's
becoming more and more synonymous for
what gets run in the cloud so web
applications
um really get a lot of the functionality
of a web application gets run in the
front end
anything with css html5 uh client-side
javascript
it's all gonna get run in the front end
everything else such as connecting to a
database um
gets run behind the scenes in the back
end
and so you know anything that's going to
have like graphics is going to be on the
front end
uh apis are going to be run on the back
end and then just finally
some of the scripting languages are
using on the front end
so html css javascript those are all
common core scripting languages that you
would use
you can use frameworks such as angularjs
and react.js or vue
those would be a front-end frameworks
back-end
frameworks will include java php python
and node.js or some of the back-end
technologies you'd also
throw in their net as well i mean it's
just the whole
you know litany of front-end and
back-end technologies and frameworks
that you can use
um and this is actually a good point to
kind of
explain the experience you have outside
of just working with node.js but
other technologies that you've been
working with that potentially that the
client is also using
so another question you're going to be
asked when you're looking at node.js is
you know can you tell me about
npm and so when somebody asks you what
is npn the first thing you can
respond is do you mean node package
manager
and the reason why you want to respond
like that is that you want to qualify
their question with understanding that
you know what they're talking about but
you want them to verify that
and so node packet manager is npm and
it's responsible for
packaging all of your modules that
you're working with
in node.js and we have a whole series of
videos
that we've done on node.js and every
single one of them
includes references to mpm
so you're going to be asking you know so
okay you've told me
um what it is you know can you go into a
little bit more um
details you know can you provide two
main functionalities and so
one of them is being able to manage
online repositories of modules and
packages
so you can go to like search.nodejs.org
and you can find a packages that you can
install into your
solution such as express js
and it also provides a command line
utility that allows you to manage
uh your packages very quickly uh through
terminal window or command line
i use vs code a lot visual studio code
and it has a command line utility built
right into it that allows you to
interact with
npm so what are some of the modules
in node.js and so you know modules
um in node.js they're essentially like
javascript
libraries so you can think of some of
the
javascript libraries that you may have
used the functionality
is somewhat the same but they're
designed for node.js
and to run on the server and there are
ways in which you can go ahead
and create some of those modules so for
instance
if we're creating a web server you can
actually use the
require commands to be able to require
that the
server be there so the example we have
on the right hand side
shows that we really do need to have
http which is a
web server and we require that to be
installed and
so that if you're running that npm
package it will actually
install the http server and then you
actually write some code to actually
then
listen on the local host port 2000
for where you'll be running your
application
and there are just you know there's a
whole bunch of modules that come
with node.js right out of the gate
and here are some of the modules that
you have and we also referenced that
just earlier on
http is a core module for running a
web server you have a utility function
that
is useful for developers to assess and
features within your node.js
project you have a url module for any
url passing you'd be doing
and you also have a stream which allows
you to be able to stream data in and out
of your system and be able to
manage how that's being worked and then
zlib which allows you to compress and
decompress
files so that you can keep your storage
of files to a minimum
so a question you're going to be asked
is you know why is node.js being
preferred over back-end technologies
such as java and php and particularly
gyro it's a very mature
stable language it's been around for
more than 20 years you know php
runs some of them the most powerful and
largest uh websites out there such as
facebook so why would you use node.js
well the first response is kind of a
gimme but it is
really fast and if you watched any of
the videos that we've done on node.js
building out solutions
and developing the solutions you'll see
just how
fast it is the second is the
really kind of the secret sauce with
node.js
is the node package manager and no
package manager
allows you to install additional
functionality such as
express or [ __ ] as a database
into your solution really quickly
and there's over 50 000 bundles
available for node package manager
if you're building out a real-time
application that's data intensive
and you need to have apis quickly
developed
then node.js is another great it's
really the great solution for you it
allows you to
build out these solutions really quickly
and there is a easy synchronization
between the server and the client
due to the code base and then finally
because the structure of node.js
is javascript if you are making the
pivot from
being a front-end web developer to
node.js
it's just going to make it a lot easier
for you to pick up
node.js because you have that common
language of javascript
and on top of that javascript is the
world's most popular
scripting language so let's talk about
some of the differences between angular
and node.js and so the reason why this
question may come up
is the person interviewing you is seeing
whether or not
you do know the difference between a
front-end
framework and a back-end framework and
this is one of those questions where you
can go well there
are differences but the differences are
because they complement each other
so angular is a front-end development
framework whereas node.js
is a server-side in framework other
differences
though between the actual frameworks
themselves is that angular is written in
typescript
which is a modification of javascript
nodejs is written in c and c plus plus
angular is used for building out single
page
client-side web applications and so
that's
a key word there is client-side whereas
node.js is about building out
fast and scalable server-side network
applications
and so again the two complement each
other
uh angular splits web applications into
the mvc and model view control
components whereas node.js generates
a lot of database grades it does more
than that as well
but you can think of node.js as that
glue to your database
so let's talk a little bit about when
you're connecting to a database
with node.js and so um you're going to
probably be asking what is
the most popular database used with
node.js
and there are a couple um mongodb is
largely the most popular nosql
cross-platform database
mysql is also very popular and that's a
more traditional relational database
um you would go with mongodb for really
more modern
solutions when you're looking at
creating an application that's going to
really scale into just managing masses
and masses
of data that has to be
created read updated and deleted
very very quickly
for some of the other popular libraries
that you use for node.js
expressjs is a very popular one i really
like working with express.js
allows me to build out web applications
really quickly
more importantly it allows me to build
out apis very quickly
and which you know apis are essentially
web applications themselves
but being able to do that very quickly
with a framework like express.js is very
useful
mongoose is an application that makes
connecting
to a [ __ ] database really easy so
here is an example of express.js which
is a
in itself really a flexible budge a
solution that you can do lots with
and mongoose which is a more focused
solution
which allows you know to you make it
easier to connect to your databases
so you know what are the pros and cons
of working with node.js there's
lots of ways we explained this earlier
on that you can actually build out
applications that run on the cloud
why would you you know what are the pros
and cons so a pro
is that node.js is extremely fast a
processing an event based
model it really is fast a con
is if you have something that is a very
heavy computational task it's not so
good at that
now i will caveat that this is that
node.js is getting better all the time
and so
you might have to be provide an example
of what a very heavy computational
task is and that may be calculating
a risk on an insurance application
against
many many variables that may be
something that's seen as
computationally very heavy but what you
can do in that example is you can
offload the task to another solution
that's designed for it and use apis
to pass the data back and forth pro
javascript is used for building out your
applications
with node.js great lots of people know
javascript a restriction and again this
is evolving as javascript itself evolves
is that when you do a call back you may
end up doing
lots of nested callbacks um if you're
doing something that's very complicated
again another way around the con and so
this is one of the things that i always
look for
is if you have a blocker or a barrier
how do you get around that barrier and
so for instance when you're talking
to your recruiter you can say look
the reason why i use node.js is that
it's fast it's event based driven
i can use javascript there are some
challenges
and but what i do to get around those
changes are
and that's where you can say that you
know you may run the complex script off
and you may write that
in net or java or php and then use an
api
to do the response back into node.js so
you get the benefits of both worlds but
minimize the investment in having to
manage
a complex environment such as java
versus a
relatively simple environment with
node.js
the node package manager makes it
extremely easy to access
just an awful lot of functionality
with over 50 000 packages there's a
package for that
so from being able to have a
tool that creates unique identifiers
that you might need to have
for generating content that gets posted
into a database
through to being able to connect to
databases through
you know to running so many different
solutions
and the npm package manager with this
access to so many
different packages makes it great for
getting access to all that content now a
con is
working with relational databases with
node.js
isn't as easy as a nosql database now
you can do it and there are ways around
that and
what i would do when this question comes
up is always kind of pivot to say
hey this is how you can actually then
get around
building out that application pro for
node.js designed for streaming huge
amounts of data in and out
a con is that node.js is singles
threaded and so it can be cpu intensive
but again there are ways around that and
a good way around that is
scaling your solution in an elastic
environment such as the cloud
so what is the command used to import an
external
library and so to import an external
library the command
is the required command so an example we
have here
is uh you can start a variable and the
variable is going to be for http
and you're going to then require the
http
service and that means that the
application itself won't run unless
the external library the http library is
installed
okay so those were our introductory
questions for node.js let's kind of
pivot and take a look at the
intermediate questions that you would be
asked
so what does event driven programming
mean so event driven programming means
that
if something happens something else will
happen in response so for instance
if you click a mouse that mouse click is
an event that means something has to
respond
to that event just think of it as cause
and effect it's
just the basic motion of physics so
that's what event driven programming
means
you also look at it as a callback
function
so that when an element is executed
something will happen
in response so what is an event
loop in node.js so an event loop
in node.js is when you do an
asynchronous call and
what that essentially means is that you
are sending out
data and then non-blocking input output
from node.js is pulling data back in
what is an event emitter in node.js
so an event emitter has really two areas
of focus one is that it manages
the classes that hold all the objects
within
your event and we have an example of
this on the right hand side
and then whenever an event actually is
thrown
the functions are then called on that
event synchronously
so for instance we have in our example
on the right hand side
we create an event and then we have the
functions and that executed
in a series from that event
so let's talk about the api functions in
node.js so there's
two types one is an asynchronous
non-blocking
function and the second is a synchronous
blocking function and the difference
between the two of them
is asynchronous is that there is no uh
structure to the order
for how the api is resolved
synchronous means that when the feedback
from the api is received
you have to execute the response
in a series for how the response is sent
to you
so what is a package.json file
so the package.json file is at the heart
of
our node.js package when we actually
will initialize a solution folder to be
a node.js
package you'll find that the package
itself holds all of the metadata
that's particular to the project you're
working on such as project name
version requirements it is you have to
have installed in the root
of the directory for the project and
again look at any of the videos that we
have
on node.js we do have demonstrations
within those videos that actually then
go through and break
out um how to create that root package
and you'll see how you can actually then
go ahead and update
the instructions or the metadata within
the package
so here we have an example of what that
metadata looks
like so again this kind of continues
that question of what is a package.json
file
and you may be asked you know what is
the metadata and why is it important and
the metadata
is a basic json
collection of pairing of
key details such as name version
description
and then the custom version that you put
so for instance
under name you could create a name for
your project there can't be any spaces
what is the version and description and
what is the
main or starting path for
the solution typically that would be
index.js but it could be anything.js
but index.js is typical simply because
index.html is the starting point for a
typical web application
so how would you use a url module in
node.js so with the url module what it
allows you to do
is really two things one is that it
provides
the resolution and passing of a url
for utilities in your application and
then it allows you to
extend your module with built-in
solutions and split up the web address
into a readable format
so in this example we have
the url and the response it would would
give
for that url which would then be
a year and month um and it'd be in a
readable format
so it would read out as
2020 and then the month so
what is express.js and you've heard me
mention this a couple of times in the
video and we actually have a separate
video on
expressjs um but express.js is a web
application framework that allows you to
build out
web solutions for both mobile and
traditional desktop right inside of
node.js so it's
very easy to use being able to install
web.js is as simple as requiring
express to be installed in the example
that we have here
on the screen it's a full solution of
showing how to actually build
out a solution with web js
so in this example you start off the
first two lines
require express to be installed and the
store comes from node packet manager
then we have a simple application that
will then send
to the browser window a hello world
message confirming that express is up
and running
and then the third block of content
starting with virus server
actually will define the port where
your application is going to run so in
this instance the
port is going to run on localhost and
the port will be port 8081
and so you can actually go to localhost
colon8081
and when you do that that will trigger
the application
that will forward up the message hello
world and it's all coming from
express.js
so what are streams and node.js so
streams are objects that allow you to
read and write data continuously back
and forth
within your application and there's
really four different
types of streams there's readable
writable
duplex and transform
the readable stream for which data can
be read
the writable streams that you can
actually write to
a duplex is a stream where it is both
readable
and writeable and
transform our streams that can be
manipulate the data
while it is being read or written
so how do you update and delete a
dependency so
say for instance we want to install
something like express so if you wanted
to install express what you would do
is you would just write them inside of
your project
you want to go to terminal window and
write in the command
mpm install express
if you want to update the
dependencies within your node package
manager to update all of them
all you have to do is write the command
npm
update all dependencies and then if you
want to
explicitly uninstall a dependency such
as express.js
that's using the uninstall command and
so that would again be
going to terminal window and you would
type npm uninstall
express and again it's really easy to
create a simple
server in node.js that will run a simple
command
the http service is actually built into
node.js you don't need to use expressjs
i typically use expressjs when i want to
do a web server because
typically what i find is that i will
want to go and do something more
complicated but if you want to do
something
that illustrates just the core
functionality
within node.js you can actually just
require the core http service that
actually comes as part of node.js
and then you can actually then go ahead
and tell it
to create a service and then to
write in plain text a command
or text string such as in this case
it'll be hello world
and that would pop out and then the
final line is to then
listen that if you go to a web browser
that's
on port 127.0.
or localhost and go to port colon
8080. once you actually go to that that
will trigger this application and you'll
get the text hello world pop up on your
screen
so explain synchronous and non-blocking
apis in node.js
so all the apis in
node.js are asynchronous which means
that they are non-blocking
which means you can run them
continuously um and
scale around that which is just
fantastic it's one of the reasons why
node.js can scale so fast and the eighth
means that the apis can return data
send data after it's been called and
really increase
the efficiency of events as they are
triggered within node.js
so how do you implement async and
node.js
and so the example that we have on the
left hand side
allows us to trigger async and it's
using the
async function and as you can see in
this example
uh it's actually something that can be
done very quickly in this example we're
actually
making a command to logo host and
app that's running on port 3000 and then
depending on
what we get if there's an error message
and then we'll have
error message go to the console log
which is the terminal window
and if we get a response to an
application
then we'll actually get a positive
response which would be
fetched response so again
very quickly and easy that you use the
async function
to be able to build out and you to get
your
asynchronous code so what is the purpose
of
module exports so a module export
is a way to encapsulate your the entire
code for a solution
in a single package in a single file and
then you can then
share that with other developers so
you're all working from
the same environment so what is a
callback function in node.js a callback
function is essentially that once you
run and you've triggered an event and
the response has been given you want to
be
able to then have a callback to validate
that
the task is complete all right let's
move on to
the final set of questions which is
advanced node.js questions
so what is reppl in node.js
so repl stands for read eval
print and loop and this is a reference
to the unix and linux
background that node.js has
so repo will form the following tasks
the read will be
actually passing the javascript you'll
read that and store it in memory
eval takes and evaluates the data
structure
print will then print the results often
on the console window or onto a web page
and then loop and loops the above
command until
the user presses ctrl c twice
what is the control flow function
so the control flow function is a piece
of code that runs
between several of the asynchronous
functions
and that's it it actually controls how
those functions
execute so how control
flow controls the function calls and it
does it through four
ways one is it controls the order of
execution
it collects the data it limits the
concurrency
and then it also calls the next step in
a program
again this is a management tool for how
your functions are called
within node.js so
what is the difference between fork and
spawn methods in
node.js so the essential difference
between the two of them
is that if you use the fork method
it will actually trigger and create a
new instance
of the v8 engine the engine running
node.js and will then run the
application
in that new instance with spawn
it's somewhat similar it doesn't
actually generate a new v8 instance so
it's actually creating a new process
but it's within the same v8 instance as
the previous application that it was
spawned from
explain to me what is the use of buffer
class in node.js
so with the buffer class what you're
looking at doing is you're actually
controlling the raw data of a set of
arrays
and integers and the memory allocation
outside of the v8 heap buffer class is
used because pure javascript is not
compatible
with binary data what
is piping in node.js so
piping is the ability to connect the
output
of one stream to another stream that
could be a data stream it could be any
stream that you're working with
but it does normally get used to pass
data from one stream to another
so what are some of the flags used in
the rewrite operation files
so r dash is used for read w's for
opening a file for writing uh a
dash is opening a file for appending um
so
the collection that you have here you
don't have to really memorize all of
them but to have a few of them
in the back of your mind is always a
good reference point
so how would you open a file using
node.js
so the syntax you would use would be
the fs.open and that would then open up
a file explain to me what
callback hell is so callback how also
known as the
pyramid of doom is when you have too
many
nested unreadable and unmanageable
callbacks
intensively cycle within each other and
they're constantly reading to each other
and they're not able to resolve the
solution
and this is a you know it's a big
problem and this is what why it's called
callback hell
because you're not able to finalize the
the app you're working on
what is a reactive pattern in node.js
and so reactor pattern is a concept of
non-blocking i o
operations can you explain to me
the test pyramid for node.js so the test
pyramid
and this is standard for testing for
all devops is really split into three
key areas you have unit tests
integration tests and then end to end or
e2e tests
the unit tests are tests that you
actually do in your raw code
that you're working on and the goal
there is to be able to
validate that the code you're writing is
consistently working
integration allows you to um have tests
that
integrate your raw code that you're
working within your application with
other areas
of an application and then end to end is
the
whole system the whole interface as it
were
for your solution describe the exit
codes of node.js
so annexa code is a specific code that
identifies the end of a specific process
and examples of exit codes are
unused uncalled fatal exception
fatal error internal javascript
evaluation area
these are all good examples of exit
codes
so what is middleware can you explain
the concept
of middleware in node.js
so with middleware it is the ability to
be able to connect
to a system and get data from it um
that's outside
of node.js so this may be executing a
type of code
or updating and modifying a request in
response to a specific type of object
and finishing the request response cycle
can you explain to me what are the types
of http requests that you may use
when working with node.js there are
actually quite a lot
but four of them that you might use
would be get post
head and delete and these are if you've
done any
web application before particularly
worked with forms inside of a web
application
you're probably very familiar certainly
with get and post
again it's the request to retrieve data
post is generally used
for changing stating and data head is
similar to get
um but also ask for a response if
there's no body content so if you're
using
if you're developing an api this would
be a good one to use and
delete is used to delete the
predetermined source
so how would you connect to mongodb
database and with node.js
and you'd use that using the [ __ ]
client and the example we have on the
left hand side
and illustrates that
what is the use of node underscore emv
and so this node underscore emv is an
environment variable that stands for
node environment
in express server so the example we have
on the right hand side
allows you to illustrate how you would
do that for say a production environment
so what are some of the various timing
features in node.js so
the timing functions that you could use
here set timeout
and then clear timeout and you to
schedule code
execution that you'd have inside of your
application
you also have set interval clear
interval to
execute a block of code up multiple
times in your application
set intermediate and clear intermediate
to
execute code that is at the end of your
application
and with that we have come to an end of
this video on node.js full course
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics covered in this video
please ask anyway in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here